what i think we do not understand and we
really underestimate is that we are
social creatures through and through 100
our culture our families our friends our
co-workers our religion our politics
name it if we do something that
separates ourselves from them in such a
way that we actually aren't connected to
a social group or many of the social
groups
it's devastating and so people are more
willing to not live according to their
values then not belong
and be part of a group especially one
that they were part of before
so the social aspects are huge people
are forgetting
that there's no other diet out there
where people feel convicted um there's
it's not a there's no other diet that
has a conviction involved so if you stop
eating that way you have to justify it
whereas you know there's people that
quit the paleo diet the keto diet
ancestral diet weston a price nourishing
traditions people quit those diets all
the time just the same as vegan as a
vegan diet plant-based diet right but
you don't see people making videos of
why i'm quitting the keto diet why i'm
quitting the paleo diet because they
don't need to justify it because there's
no conviction involved it's not a big
deal it's like no one cares you quit the
keto diet or whatever but if you quit
veganism when you stood up for it for
like an ethical reason you have to have
something to justify it like what even
is the vegan diet anyways there's a
hundred different ways to eat a
plant-based diet i would
ask anyone who was raised to hunt or
fish or whatever where there's a direct
assault against another animal i would
ask them if they didn't have to be
desensitized because you have to teach
cruelty you have to teach violence and
i've heard so many stories from men and
women who say
my husband my father first took me out i
didn't want to go and he said you got to
be a man you got to do this and it hurt
i didn't want to and i cried and it was
terrible and then you know what it got
easier that's called desensitization
that's not optimal that's not where we
want to be as a species we want to be in
touch with the
most
integral parts of who we are
that was calling patrick goudreau a
thought leader on the social ethical and
practical aspects of living
compassionately and healthfully she's a
speaker cultural commentator podcaster
and author of many books including the
joyful vegan how to stay vegan in a
world that wants you to eat meat dairy
and eggs i have been looking forward to
this episode since the creation of my
podcast one of my most passionate topics
is this conversation surrounding why
people stop being vegan how vegans
respond to people who stop being vegan
how non-vegans use the stories of
ex-vegans as proof or justification for
this or that the complexities of our own
stories lenses and experiences that
shape our decisions and so on i haven't
really touched on this topic before so
it's the perfect place to do so
millions of people are choosing veganism
all over the world they value their
health have compassion for animals and
are concerned about the environment and
yet despite the personal benefits they
experience a lot of people revert back
to eating meat dairy and eggs why is
that
colleen is an og vegan she's been vegan
for decades and her perspective on the
many common reasons why people stop
being vegan are compelling in this
episode we cover the social and cultural
pressures that impact people's lifestyle
choices how the fear of the unknown and
fear of change can be overwhelming
social media influencers who quit being
vegan when plant-based diets don't work
the hidden complexities of our modern
day agricultural system how to respond
compassionately to everyone's viewpoints
and if vegans righteous anger when
people fail to meet their expectations
is justified or helpful we talk about
our biological design to thrive if i
ever considered stop being vegan finding
supportive community and bringing people
together feeling pressure often
self-inflicted to be perfect and so on
i have a lot of friends who are not
vegan or plant-based or used to be vegan
and are not plant-based anymore i love
them all just the same what's so
important to understand when navigating
this topic or any topic really with
opposing polarizing perspectives for
that matter is that people are generally
doing their best with the information
they have and what feels right for them
everyone is going through life with
different lenses on based on their
experiences information they come across
and stories that shape their lives so be
confident yes be strong in your
convictions yes but also have compassion
for others and where they are coming
from i'll likely be doing a part two of
this episode in the future with a
nutrition expert honing in more focused
and more specifically on when people
stop being vegan for health reasons but
for now i hope you enjoy this long
awaited episode i've been wanting to
make for ages we cover so much it's so
fascinating so let's get into it welcome
to the podcast everyone i am so excited
for this conversation
since the beginning of this podcast
since the creation of it one of the most
important episodes i wanted to create
was why people stop being vegan how to
stop being vegan what are the steps that
would take for people to get to that
point and i can't think of a better
person to have this discussion with than
you colleen you're a close friend with
my sister and you have an entire book on
this exact topic the joyful vegan and
what's the and the title after that how
to stay vegan in a world that wants you
to eat meat dairy and eggs right so how
long have you been vegan
i've been vegan for 23 years it's my
23rd year wow that is quite a long time
and so you've seen all the different
kinds of trends pop up and over the
years
what have you seen like right you know
right now we're seeing something
different than it was even a few years
ago or five years ago you know veganism
was really trendy
three four five years ago and now it's
kind of shifted based on what you see on
social media maybe not with the numbers
in regards to there's always new people
going vegan there's all these people
that are that are vegan and staying
vegan but what you see online had kind
of shifted do you feel like it was like
that when you first were vegan or what
was it like back then no there wasn't an
online when i first went vegan right so
it's hard to compare i you know i was
talking to hannah about this actually
that i think because
the internet is so
fast and it's in our faces all the time
we think it's a different reality than
what has been in the past before
there was the internet and i just would
caution people to draw conclusions based
on what we're seeing right in front of
us because people became vegan and
stopped being vegan before the internet
and what you also have are people
actually making videos that say i'm not
vegan any longer and so people freak out
and panic and think it's happening more
than i think it actually is it's like a
news reporter doesn't come and say there
are no hurricanes today and there's been
no mass shootings yes we don't we don't
talk about that so there aren't as many
people who are going on and making
videos saying i'm still vegan today
got nothing else
but it's it's so trendy you're trying
you know click bait sure whatever but
that's just the that's just the trend
right now and that doesn't necessarily
reflect reality that doesn't mean there
isn't something to talk about people do
stop being vegan people struggle staying
vegan and people resist becoming vegan
and those are all the things to talk
about i would just caution drawing
you know conclusions based on anecdotal
internet right
right i mean you have you gave a perfect
example there it's the same thing for
like online restaurant reviews or even
podcast reviewing for some reason people
are more likely to want to leave a
review if they have negative feedback
than positive feedback and that goes for
anything so
it's just like what you said you're not
really going to be seeing the things
blow up in the internet like i'm still
vegan
right but i'm no longer vegan is very
very clicky and we're gonna i'm so
excited to unpack all of it today so
let's like just lay the groundwork a
little bit
in your book and what you talk about a
lot on your own podcast is about how
millions of people are choosing veganism
they feel motivated for a wide variety
of reasons not only for their own health
but also the environment and for the
compassion
aspect for the animals yet a lot of
people don't stay vegan and so can you
kind of unpack what your thoughts are as
to why and then we'll get into each one
yeah well i would even back up and say
that i think what's really important to
talk about is why people resist becoming
vegan in the first place what what it
means how the general public sees what
veganism means and how it tends to be
seen as something different than who
they are that it's not a part of their
identity that it's not a part of their
ideology that it's not a part of their
value system so i think if we can really
unpack what it means to be vegan first
then i think we can better understand
why people look at it and go that's not
me or when they try they go this isn't
working
so for me the way i think about veganism
is that you know i often say that i
didn't become vegan as much as i removed
the blocks to the compassion that was
already inside of me that's it that
literally i was a person like millions
and millions of other people who was got
kind and good and compassionate and
cared about animals and just didn't want
to hurt anybody period like that's it
and i do think we are inclined toward
compassion we're also inclined toward
cruelty i mean it's not that we are
you know not potentially cruel or not
potentially compassionate but i do think
we tend toward compassion and that's
what we're reared in our parents teach
us it our parents stoke it so do our
teachers so do adults right look at all
of the things i mean you know as a
mother look at all of the films and the
movies and the movies and films are the
same thing uh the films the tv shows the
games the books the songs the costumes
the stuffed animals the wallpaper the
decoration for kids clothing everything
in every way we are encouraged to have a
connection with other animals in every
way
and and that's
who i was now i often talk about the
fact that you don't have to love animals
to not want to hurt them right you don't
have to be an animal lover and that's
what an expression we tend to use it can
be a little condescending because i
don't think you have to be an animal
lover to not want to commit violence
against them right but i was that kid i
was the kid who just loved being around
animals i intervened when anybody was
suffering and i didn't want to hurt them
and my parents supported that
but my parents were also feeding the
animals
and so there's this compartmentalization
that happens that we're not aware of my
parents weren't aware like i'm gonna
make you love
you know our dog but hate cows right yes
it's very subconscious it's so
subconscious and it's also status quo
and they're not thinking about it
because it's what they were taught and
what they see all around them even to
the point of sub compartmentalization
because i would go to the zoo the
petting zoo there'd be cows there i'd
pet cows but i'd go home and eat them
right or goats or whatever it was we
didn't eat goats much but you get the
idea i mean chickens same the same thing
right but even dogs we compartmentalize
we have this notion that like oh yeah
dogs who are in a home should be taken
care of but dogs who are in research
laboratories well they're there to help
the human race so we are so capable of
compartmentalizing our values our
thoughts are you know what we care about
and that's what we do and so you
basically what happens is what i think
is a very broad general open
unconditional compassion when we're
young
right
starts to become blocked and we start to
put up these walls and barriers so that
that compassion becomes covered up and
it becomes conditional then you start to
say well animals are here for us if it
helps me and we're going to starve
otherwise and like that's how we got big
brains and like we start telling
ourselves the things we need to to
justify the thing that we're doing that
then becomes habit
and so ultimately that compassion that i
had that was like so beautiful and so
pure and so perfect becomes just like
quelled
it's there i was still a compassionate
person i didn't walk around hurting
anybody right but you start to make
these excuses and that to me is the
beautiful awakening of when you
encounter the thing that makes you open
your eyes and say i want to chip away at
that wall i want to get rid of it
sometimes it happens like that if you
just read something or see something and
that's where the rawness comes in and
we'll talk about that but to me that's
what being vegan is it's the awakening
to the compassion that is already inside
of you and i'm using compassion
self-compassion applies as well if
you're eating in a way that's really
harmful to you you're not seeing it
you're covering that up you're making
you you know not a priority right so
it's the same idea is when you encounter
the thing that makes you
literally wake up um that that the
blocks to that fall away and you just
want to do the right thing before there
was a word called vegan people
wanted to do the right thing and and not
harm animals this goes
back thousands of years it just wasn't
called veganism especially with the way
that we teach our children to be kind to
the animal that's in front of us be nice
to the kitty don't pull on the kitty's
tail gentle pick up the duck very
carefully
we're teaching them all these things on
how to be gentle because you would never
want to see a child that's like
purposely harming or hurting an animal
for the kick of it right but when they
use it as a justification well we're
doing this like to eat the animal and
it's all separated from what they're
seeing
then it completely changes
how they feel about it
it's even it's so much more profound
than that because
we
know we have enough data we know that
that
kindness towards animals is a barometer
for mental well-being we know we can
look at serial killers we could look at
mass shooters the one that just happened
we can look at that history and see the
animal cruelty and violence against
animals when they were young
and we know that if there is violence
towards animals it's enough that it's
violence towards animals but we know we
can draw a direct line to they are going
to be violent against humans the
likelihood is very very high and we also
know then the flip side
if we are kind and compassionate and
have empathy and see that someone else
suffers and that includes animals uh
we're less inclined to hurt others so
it's
this literally teaches us how to be
social beings and how to be good kind
social beings and not hurt anybody i'm
thinking about the people who also just
listening to what you're saying totally
agreeing in agreement with what you're
saying i'm also thinking about the
people listening who are like well
there's a difference between you know
shooting an animal
hunting and even maybe teaching your
child to do that raising them up so that
they're like connected to their food
right that's what they that's what they
feel is like best for their family and
um and doing that in a way is different
than they say as abusing animals so
there's a there's and a lot of times
wow it's so interesting when someone
maybe makes that connection you're
talking about becomes vegan and then the
topic we're going to talk about stops
being vegan and then shifts their
mindset something i really don't like is
when i see vegans try to say oh they
will never really vegan in the first
place
it's like okay come on no if somebody
stopped being vegan
maybe for health reasons or they really
started to believe oh i actually need
this to be healthy which i is something
that i tend to see
happens a lot as the biggest motivator
for someone stopping being vegan but
there's also the social and cultural
things that we'll get into too but then
you have to shift your mindset and go
well okay i
do think that we need animals to to be
healthy so like the least harm is
possible right like like if we can kill
them in a way that's quote unquote
ethical and so let's get into that sure
yeah so let's unpack that so first of
all it's one of the reasons i tend to
talk about violence against animals
rather than abuse because abuse you can
quantify and you can you can say that's
abuse but that's not abuse etc right
there is no way to end a life without
that being fighting to live and to take
that life from that animal
person being whoever um they're fighting
to live and there is violence in that
and what i would say even going back
farther than that so that's just one of
the reasons why i don't tend to use
abuse
the word abuse but
i would
ask anyone who was raised to hunt or
fish or whatever where there's a direct
assault against another animal i would
ask them if they didn't have to be
desensitized because you have to teach
cruelty you have to teach violence you
have to teach that kind of aggression
and i've heard so many stories from men
and women who say
my husband my father first took me out i
didn't want to go and he said you got to
be a man you got to do this and it hurt
i didn't want to and i cried and it was
terrible and then you know what it got
easier that's called desensitization
that's not optimal that's not where we
want to be as a species we want to be in
touch with the
most
integral parts of who we are not
desensing desensitizing ourselves so
what are the options you're either
desensitized to the suffering you're
causing not great or
you're so flippant about it that you're
apathetic and you don't care that you
could just hurt someone without caring
that's sociopathic so
which would you choose i would choose
trying to do the best we can to get
ourselves out of the way and our desires
and wants out of the way and say well
how is what i'm doing affecting somebody
else and how can i live in such a way
that is true to my values and also being
as compassionate as possible yeah i mean
you're so right because i even talked to
my mom who grew up on a farm in indiana
and before she was plant-based we'd have
conversations about it you know like the
dairy farm she grew up on and
and like the pig and stuff and i
remember her telling me yeah i was
really sad the first time that i
realized that we killed the animals that
like the oh the pig's gone the family
pig is gone where did the pig go we had
to kill the pig and she remembers
feeling sad about that now she told me
this before she was plant-based and so
when she said but you know like then i
just got used to it and it was fine so
it's exactly what you said she eats
plant-based now and i'm sure she's
listening to this episode love you mom
um
and so that's a really really valid
point but i also think it's helpful i
think for vegans who are listening to
this and want to just jump to
conclusions name call which i have
listened to you on your podcast talk
about how unhelpful that is
saying like you're
causing a disservice to the cause or
like how dare you or you're just this or
that name calling right
not empathizing with their what they're
really feeling inside so like if
somebody really does believe they need
animal foods to be healthy if they you
know they thought they could do veganism
and then whatever bumps along the road
come in the way and they are convinced
now through whatever things have
convinced them that they need animal
foods to be healthy then they're gonna
they're doing their best to what they
feel like is the circle of life so what
are your thoughts on that oh sure so of
course yeah i mean we hear that a lot
right so i mean you know one of the more
common things we hear people say is well
animals eat other animals so it's
natural for us to do so as well where
animals were part of the cycle of life
the question i have is like which
animals are you talking about because
the majority of the animal kingdom is
actually made up of herbivores and so
again we're just kind of using this
this excuse to
justify our own behavior and you know we
can unpack the whole like well of course
lions who are killing other animals
they're not doing it out of you know
lack of morals they're doing it because
they're literally built as carnivores
and we have morals and we don't have to
align ourselves with a lion because we
can make choices they can't i mean we
can do that they also do things that we
would never do of course i mean there's
so many things i mean right we could get
into that right it's like who do you
want to compare yourself to you know
same thing with the cavemen the brains
maybe big and like that's what we've
always done it's like do you want to
compare yourself to neanderthals or do
you want to compare yourself to the best
you could possibly be i would rather
just compare myself to the best we could
possibly be especially since we have new
information that we have not had before
right so so we have to decide what our
barometer is but it's a knee-jerk
reaction um and as i said we never use
the elephant as the barometer we use the
lion how come we don't say well
elephants don't eat other animals so we
shouldn't either we don't do that we say
lions eat other animals we should too so
it's we're you know kind of cherry
picking what what's convenient for us so
i don't think in the end someone is
literally ordering a hamburger because
they think
i'm like a lion and i'm gonna align
myself with it they're just using it as
a way to feel better and so so to go
back to the idea of why people avoid
being vegan or or
what cognitive dissonance is so
cognitive dissonance this is literally
trying to
mitigate cognitive dissonance dissonance
means that you are uncomfortable with
the thing
that you're doing you're not able to
reconcile something you're doing with
your belief system
behavior beliefs you have two options if
you are dissonant you can either change
your behavior to align with your beliefs
or you could change your beliefs to
align with your behavior that's all this
is so people who become vegetarian or
vegan or whatever they're aligning their
behavior with their beliefs there's
someone harmed or it's not healthy for
me or whatever i'm going to stop eating
that
what we all tend to do majority-wise
because it's easier is we change our
thinking to align with our behavior
because we don't want to change our
behavior but we still have to believe
we're good people we still have to
believe we're doing the right thing we
still have to believe that we're doing
this because we have to despite the fact
that we don't really want to i'm sure
you've heard that a million times where
people say i didn't really want to go
back to eating animals but i had to
we give away our agency because of
the excuse we're making when in reality
there's probably some more unpacking to
do with that there's always more
unpacking for sure and to be clear i
have a lot of friends who are not
plant-based or who used to be
plant-based or not anymore and i
actually i do have a lot of empathy for
like people are just doing the best that
they can based on what with the
information that they have and so
i don't look at that as someone like in
in an ill-mannered way like i really do
believe people are just trying to do
their best and
there's a lot of confusing information
out there for people and
yeah i just want to reiterate that that
like as much as like i
like love this topic of like unpacking
the reasons and stuff like i feel like
empathy goes such a long way rather than
like
like divisiveness
you know
um but keep going yeah no 100 i mean the
whole point is that we've all been there
i mean that's one of the things i talk
about in the joyful vegan is we have to
remember that we were went there as well
i made excuses i made you know
justifications we all do and that's the
point is that when i was eating animals
i wasn't an uncompassionate person it
was just blocked and so if we can in
every way look at other people where we
see ourselves in them and we see them in
ourselves we're going to be more
inclined to be connected and to
understand and so what i try to do when
i'm communicating about this with other
people wherever they are on their
spectrum i don't ask people before i
talk to them how they eat what their
belief system is i just talk to people
uh but what i try to do is speak to
their compassion and know that it's
there and so that's what we're talking
about we're not talking about the fact
that everybody is you know at a
different place and has different
struggles it's the question is if you
start making those kinds of excuses
there's something there that you're
trying to hold on to a belief and defend
against it and if you want to talk about
it we can talk about it but um the
beautiful thing about becoming vegan for
me was i never had to make any more
excuses that's the thing that was just
so liberating and i still feel that
every day and it's been you know a long
time yeah i feel the same way something
i've seen you say is that people stay or
stop being vegan depending on how well
they navigate the social cultural and
emotional aspects of living vegan in a
non-vegan world can you unpack that a
little bit yeah yeah i feel like the
early part of my work was about the
practical aspects and the nutritional
aspects and the culinary aspects and
then there's all of this around the
emotional and the cultural and the
social and i think it's where a lot of
i don't want to generalize but it's
where it's where people
who stop remembering what it was like
before you have to remember what it was
like before you were vegan it's so easy
to just like have this new mindset and
forget what it was like
and one of the things that i hear from a
lot of people who are critical of people
who stop being vegan is you know they
never really care they never were vegan
we can talk about that that's a bit of
kind of rhetorical excommunication
so that's a different topic but what i
think we do not understand and we really
underestimate is that we are social
creatures through and through 100
a hundred percent and so
having a sense of belonging really
matters to us and when we feel outside
of especially a tribe that we were once
part of our tribes our culture our
families our friends our co-workers our
religion our politics name it if we do
something that separates ourselves from
them in such a way that we actually
aren't connected to a social group or
many of the social groups
it's devastating and so people are more
willing to not live according to their
values than not belong
and be part of a group especially one
that they were part of before
so the social aspects are huge and it's
really naive to think otherwise and it's
really naive to think that some people
are more inclined
they should be able to do it like why
would that you know when we talk about
celebrities people talk about
celebrities like their higher beings
like they don't struggle with the same
things we ordinary beings struggle with
it's ridiculous we're all social beings
we all want to fit in but we also want
to fit in
and feel good it's not just a matter of
belonging which is why you could belong
to vegan you know
groups and feel pretty crappy
because you're made to feel bad about
not being perfect or whatever the
criticism is so it's not just about
having a sense of belonging it's also
about feeling good and if you're in a
position where you're getting criticized
by the group that you think should be
the one supporting you yes
and they're not all and these are
generalizations you may step away from a
group that's you know like they don't
represent all vegans obviously if you're
in a group full of cranky vegans get out
of the group like you know you want to
stop being vegan like just get out of
the group or stop talking to that person
or whatever
but
but
that's the reason why
it's not uncommon or it's not crazy that
someone would say i didn't really feel
good being part of that community i feel
better being part of a community who
don't criticize me but that means i'm
going to start eating animals the
problem with that though is there's this
black and white mentality so again
that's you know on you you have to
not do one or the you can still have a
community feel good and stay vegan and
you can also still be connected to your
non-vegan community without eating
animal products so yeah there's a
there's a lot of nuance there totally i
think that that's a concern i see a lot
of the you know i don't like what this
group is representing i don't like the
way that they're acting you know like so
i don't want to be a part of that group
i once saw someone that i follow who's
definitely not vegan i follow her for
like other things but i see what she
shares about like her she's very pro
animal
foods way of eating and one time she had
shared online that the the most hateful
horrible people she's ever experienced
online are vegans
and i respond back to her because we've
talked sometimes and
i said that's really interesting that
that's been your experience i'm really
sorry that that's been in your
experience
for a little perspective the most
hateful nasty people i've ever
experienced online are anti-vegans and
there's hateful people in every group
and so whatever group you're aligning
with especially if you're out on social
media you're going to be getting it from
the other side
and the people who are nasty in
whichever group are just they're just
amplified they're just louder that's
just the way it is it doesn't mean
that's like the representation of the
group because there's no there's no
group anyways if you really think about
there's no um
like one thought process of any group
there's all different kinds of people
and all different kinds of
things like you said politics
spirituality religion you know eating
different ways of eating so all that is
so important to take into consider but
unfortunately because of social media
and the power that it has in influencing
people
it's very easy for the loud part of a
certain group to become the dominant
like viewpoint of like oh this must be
the group and what they think and how
they feel for sure and it gives away our
power to say i stopped being vegan
because they were jerks i mean that's
not
empowering right you just you don't
don't you let their
stuff determine what your behavior is
and of course it
they do not represent everybody there's
just gonna be you know cranky people in
every group even just the thing you said
about giving away your power earlier
about like i need animal foods to be
healthy
is a really interesting thing to
contemplate because
if you really say like i need these
specific animals like these five animals
right not i don't need you know i don't
need monkey me i don't need lion meat i
need these specific five or six animals
and if i don't get those i'm not gonna
be healthy it really is giving away your
power and your ability to nourish
yourself without
like without those specific food groups
that you consider food groups right i
think that's fascinating too it is
fascinating well you're also revealing a
bit of the cultural bias because we you
know we talk about how i crave this
particular thing or i need that animal
like there are cultures who don't eat
those animals and there are things that
we eat that other cultures don't eat so
we're we're also just kind of revealing
a cultural bias um which is also why
it's worth talking about the other part
of the beginning of the book and we're
going to get to the
the
stopping being vegan but but willful
blindness is a like it is a thing and
it's really powerful it's the thing that
enables you to look at what you're doing
and not see it and we all do it and we
all did it and that's what those excuses
and those layers of justifications are
for i talk about in that chapter that
there are slaughterhouse workers
the way the slaughterhouse system is set
up is so that most people don't see
what's happening
and the one who does he's the scapegoat
because everybody else could say i
didn't do that that was him he's the one
who did the final did the final deed
right so
we're so good at compartmentalizing and
justifying our baby that we could even
do it even while
and i'll say this too even while you
know the the narrative of well i'm gonna
kill my animal with respect and love i
mean that's a ritual that is there to
mask discomfort that's what rituals do
so even this notion this narrative that
i'm going to pray
i mean if it wasn't out of necessity
right if this is still out of kind of
pleasure and you know i mean i think
it's a lot of what we're doing today
there's not a lot of people who are
killing out of necessity some not a lot
not the people listening on this podcast
these are the people we're talking to
we're not talking to people who are
living in you know in like a a a native
land far out
in huts like we're not talking about the
eskimos that live far away no access to
anything that is not what we're talking
about like eating animals to survive is
a completely different completely
different and most people are not doing
that yeah so even the idea that well i
did it and i hunted with my father and
it was and and i prayed and like you
know and i let you know i hate this like
the native americans who what native
americans that's like that's also just
like this ridiculously romanticized
version of what we want to believe they
were as diverse as any population and so
you can't just draw these conclusions
and say these things the point is those
are also ways to mask our discomfort and
so
what my hope is that we can just get to
this place of being honest with
ourselves and just being open to
conversation and just being open to what
our hearts are really telling us because
they know and then when we started this
rationalizing that's just getting
farther away yeah it hurts well i think
the the topic of like you know eating
out of our pleasure and comfort cultural
stuff i feel like that's one kind of
area when it's like the social cultural
norms
what's easier right and then using those
justifications there but when it comes
to like eating what we don't think is a
necessity because we're like you have
other options there are a lot of people
who really do believe that they need
animal foods to be healthy like they
really really do believe that and that
tends to be at least on social media
what i see when people stop being vegan
they believe they say well i had this
specific health issue or these things
came up
and this is why i had to stop being
vegan and i know that probably the
majority of the reason why people stop
being vegan isn't because of that but
you just don't see it online as much the
specific ones that get a lot of clicks
or that are um
something that people are looking at a
lot is when someone stops being vegan
and they say i had to stop for my health
so while we're saying yes you don't have
to out of necessity they really do
believe that they need these animal
foods to be healthy so should we get
into that one first and then we'll get
into social because i think that is
actually the most interesting aspect to
me sure
right so sure so what do you want to so
what do you want to say well okay
there's so many things i want to say
in regards to this topic both from
personal experience of lots of friends
because i've been vegan for 15 years so
like i've seen people come and go
and then also just like having friends
who aren't vegan that really do believe
that they need animal foods to be
healthy love and respect them we have a
different opinion and we dabble in
discussion and we talk about it but the
day we disagree right but i'm most
interested in like when people stop
being vegan and they change their mind
on saying that they need animal foods to
be healthy what's fascinating to me is
that online people are very influenced
by those anecdotes by those stories like
oh look someone they already tried being
vegan it didn't work for them so they
have to eat animal foods like maybe we
all need animal foods like maybe i'm
missing something i've only been vegan a
few years i mean i feel fine but like
that person doesn't feel fine and then
all these things happen right all these
people are influenced by that
what's so interesting to me though that
people aren't considering they're like
looking at tunnel vision instead of
looking at the bigger picture and
realizing that when they that person's
first one vegan they also said the same
thing that they feel so much better now
that they're vegan then when they stop
being mean they go i feel so much better
now that i eat animal foods but they're
forgetting that they said that the same
thing when they first went vegan and
then also not realizing that we're
unlikely to hear an update a few years
later down the road how you feeling
three four years later five years later
seven years later are you really trying
to tell me that health issue is never
ever going to come up in those next
three to seven years
that's what's fascinating to me this
unrealistic expectation that when you're
vegan you must be in perfect health all
the time no one is in perfect health all
the time no one i don't know a single
person people that i know who advocate
for all different diets like they don't
none of them feel perfect all the time
like there's always going to be
something not always but things are
going to come up sometimes
so the other factor is exaggeration it's
just the truth that when people
are going to quit being vegan they have
to justify it you have to really really
believe at your core
that i need to stop being vegan because
if you really were vegan for animals and
the environment and for your own health
the only way it's going to make sense is
if you can explain that like look i
didn't feel well that's the strongest
justification because at the end of the
day you're going to have to take care of
yourself you have to feel you want to
feel your best
um and you can't blame someone from when
you feel their best like i have a couple
friends who are ethical vegans that i
think are more ethical vegans than me
and they say even if i was convinced
that like being vegan is not healthy i
would say being vegan i'm like well
that's not most people like most people
are at the end of the day i think gonna
want to feel good and if it was like
somehow proven in the ethers right you
know
but so that's gonna exist but for the
most part you really can't blame someone
for wanting to be healthy so if at the
end of the day they're saying look i
felt really poor on this diet i had to i
have to eat animal foods now that's
what's so interesting to me because
there's no other diet people are
forgetting
that there's no other diet out there
where people feel convicted um there's
it's not a con there's no other diet
that has a conviction involved so if you
stop eating that way you have to justify
it whereas you know there's people that
quit the paleo diet the keto diet
ancestral diet western a price weston a
price nourishing traditions people quit
those diets all the time just the same
as vegan as a vegan diet plant-based
diet right but you don't see people
making videos of why i'm quitting the
keto diet why i'm quitting the paleo
diet because they don't need to justify
it because there's no conviction
involved it's not a big deal it's like
no one cares you quit the keto diet or
whatever but if you quit veganism when
you stood up for it for like an ethical
reason you have to have something to
justify it now that's not to say that a
health issue didn't actually come up
with these people but it's more just the
realistic expectations and how much is
something being exaggerated and how did
you actually eat when you were vegan
because there are so many ways like what
even is the vegan diet anyways there's a
hundred different ways to eat a
plant-based diet that's right anyways
i've gone on and on but this is
something i could talk about for a while
this is what bothers me because i feel
like it's just so unrealistic to say
look i ate this way and i didn't
feel well even though we know that you
did like you said in a lot of different
forms online that you did feel really
great you even said in the beginning and
so now okay in the beginning you're
feeling better because of this that
maybe that's true but how are you gonna
feel three five years from now ten years
now are you gonna are you gonna be
willing to say if a health issue comes
up oh maybe it's because i'm meaning
animal products or have you already
decided that look
because a lot of times there's this
expectation when you're vegan that like
you got to be perfect health all the
time but if you're not vegan if a health
issue comes up it's like oh that's just
life
and now a word from our sponsors
father's day is just around the corner
and i rarely know what to gift my
husband andrew but this year i found the
perfect gift that he's going to be
stoked on enter manscaped i got him a
new face and body shaving set including
the lawnmower 4.0 the weed whacker and
the plow i also got him performance
boxer briefs and this travel bag to hold
everything the perfect set to take care
of his hot dad bod basically manscaped
is designed with fathers in mind and
their shavers are perfect for the dad in
your life especially on father's day
where you can surprise him and show him
extra love and appreciation the
lawnmower 4.0 will be the gift every dad
once on father's day their fourth
generation trimmer features a cutting
edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their advanced skin
save technology it's waterproof and also
has a 400k led spotlight he needs for a
more precise shave but you don't want to
stop there manscaped just launched their
brand new boxers 2.0 that are dare i say
the best boxers ever we all know dads
love their comfort with summer just
around the corner the boxers 2.0 are
here to save every father from the
uncomfortable heat whether he's mowing
the lawn taking out the trash or playing
baseball with the kids these boxers
breathe without breaking a sweat ladies
gift is going to be a hit with your man
your dad your brother and every man in
your life so get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code ellen
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com and use the
code ellen trust me his dad bod will
thank you we're also brought to you
today by buffy i can say without a doubt
that buffy enhances my sleep and every
time a friend or guest lays down in
these sheets and comforter because i
also have them set up in arahana they
are blown away how soft and cozy it is
buffy is dedicated to making a positive
impact on not only our sleep but also
the environment using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed the cloud comforter is covered in
ultra breathable eucalyptus fabric which
uses 10 times less water than cotton to
grow and its fiber is produced using
recyclable earth-friendly solvents
eucalyptus also naturally soothes the
skin for an incredible relaxing night's
sleep the best part for me though is
that the average down comforter harms 12
geese but buffy's comforter is cruelty
free using 100 recycled water bottles
that are transformed and given a second
life as super fluffy fiber it feels even
softer than down while keeping
approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans this comforter has
over 18 000 5 star reviews and keeps you
at the perfect temperature so you feel
cozy without overheating it's
hypoallergenic and machine washable
thanks to an innovative stitching
pattern that keeps its fluffy fill in
place so use my code ellen for twenty
dollars off orders over eighty dollars
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free if you don't love it return it
at no cost yeah for sure thoughts okay
thoughts oh my gosh there's a lot to say
in response to that there's like a ten
minute mall no it's i mean i know it's i
know it can be really frustrating and
you know there's there's a lot to say
about that number one is
number one is our response to it like
you know
these videos you know you just okay
so you don't hear people making videos
who say here's the thing i really wanted
to be vegan buddy i was just bored or it
was inconvenient or my parents didn't
like it or my friends didn't like it and
i really just wanted to have that burger
you just don't hear that you just don't
you hear a layer of justification
because
because you sound like a scoundrel if
you're like i really love animals but i
really like eating burgers i really like
cows but i really like their flesh i
mean like you know you don't sound so
good but if it's i really love them but
i had no choice and that's what we hear
and i don't buy that i don't buy it of
course there's going to be people who
have health health issues and reasons
but
as you said
i veganism is not a diet and i don't
mean this in the way that a lot of
ethical vegans talk about it i don't
mean like it's a way of living and it's
an ethical stance it's not what i'm
talking about vegan isn't a diet it is
literally a spectrum of how you can eat
without eating animal products there are
a gazillion ways to eat so to say that
because i was vegan i felt good or
because i was vegan i felt bad
is is is too
it's it's not accurate because
i do think there is a lot around when i
stop eating animal products i feel
better because there's just so much that
it just wreaks havoc on our body just
just you know animal flesh and fluids
but to say i ate vegan and therefore
didn't feel well
that you have to understand what people
were eating were you just eating
strawberries all day were you eating
only potato chips all day were you not
eating any gluten were you eating only
gluten were you not eating sugar were
you eating only sugar were you eating a
lot of things that were different than
what you were eating before you it's
just it doesn't even make any sense so
when i hear someone say i was vegan i
didn't feel well and i stopped
first of all if they're asking my
opinion
and most aren't
i'll ask them back what were you eating
and i find that this is not going to be
the university of youtube who's going to
actually say this because they're
getting clicks and they have their
channel and they have their followers
who are looking for confirmation bias
but if it's an actual conversation with
a person which is what i'm more
interested in i'm not interested in the
university of youtube because it's not a
thing right it's just not it's just not
where we should be getting any of our
information um not not not health
information
so i'll come back to that but but if i'm
having a conversation with someone and
they say i really wanted to i wanted to
stay viewing but i was getting really
tired i was getting you know i just
didn't feel i was kind of lethargic and
i go what were you eating they go yeah i
was kind of eating crap i really wasn't
eating that well and i know i could
probably have done it better like i just
put it back on them and they respond
because they're being self-reflective
versus me saying first of all i'm not
going to deny that they didn't feel well
if they didn't feel what they didn't
feel i'm not going to say yes you did
you felt fine like who am i i don't know
right and so the way you see in the
comments which again it's not the real
world it is not the real world i know it
feels like it's the real world it's not
how people communicate with each other
it's not how we engage with each other
so all the comments from the people who
are like right on i'm not gonna be vegan
anymore either okay
right on um you know i knew it was
really bad or people who were like
you're awful of course of course you can
be vegan and feel good that's not what
the person's saying
i mean so we so a i don't think it's the
medium to have a conversation like that
but what i'm trying to do is just offer
a perspective
of like
why someone is doing that's because they
have a youtube channel
you're not going to see in the comments
all of the people who are going to say
i'm still going to stay vegan no matter
what or i'm going to say vegan despite
you you i know that we are
social creatures who do follow each
other but i don't think we're lemmings i
don't think that the second someone
we're following says something different
we go in
and follow them we just don't i just
don't i think we all inspire each other
we influence each other and some may
have we give people more weight than
others but i'm not worried about that
for me all i can do as someone who
represents and advocates for living
compassionately and healthfully is i can
only do my work and i can only keep
putting the truth out there and i can't
worry about the people who are putting
what is their truth out there i'm not
going to be able to shut them down now
if you want to reach out to every single
one of them and say how can i help you
can do that
um if they really want help they
probably know where to find you so we
have to i think also separate what's
happening here
i see that as information i might say
maybe there's something i need to hear
about what they're saying so that in my
work i can make sure i'm speaking to
them and that's what i've been doing for
a long time is if i'm hearing something
that might be
we hear it a lot i want to be able to
provide an answer for it not because i'm
trying to defend against what they're
doing but because i want to be able to
give other people a way to think about
it differently that they might be able
to then
integrate into their own way of thinking
and then also be able to
articulate it to the to the world but we
just can't we just can't control all of
this there's there's been anti-there
have been anti-vegans before the
internet i mean there just have been
right and so
i would just rather us focus our energy
on the thing that we know to be the most
authentic the most true
the most accurate and and the rest isn't
ours they're gonna keep doing it but we
would bang ourselves against their heads
against the wall yeah yes totally i
think that the real life stories are the
ones that you're talking about face to
face that's what you're seeing a lot
more often than what is blown up in
social media but i do think that what is
blown up in social media does hold a lot
of weight for a lot of people like some
people are very easily influenced by
seeing anecdote after anecdote
especially like you're saying in the
comments they go oh same here i quit you
know however many years ago because or
however many months ago because this was
happening and now i feel so much better
people can literally look at an
anonymous condiment like that and
have some kind of bias that clips in
their head and be like yep there's
another confirmation there's another
confirmation so i do think it is more
influential than we realize like in
person a lot of people don't even have
that many vegan people in their life so
what they see online is what they see
about veganism so that's why i think it
is worth discussing because it has a lot
of weight um to a lot of people a lot of
people are very easily influenced by
like you said influencers and i myself
am on youtube too um but i try my best
to only share
like you know like this is the infra
this is where i'm getting the
information from from evidence-based you
know um practitioners go check out these
books if you'd like to go look into it
for yourself and just kind of sharing
this is what i'm doing um but people
like you said at the end they shouldn't
just be taking some influencer online or
some youtuber online and what they do
and then if they stop doing something
that means oh no that must mean i need
to stop doing something like check in
with your heart um but yeah just the
factor of
why people stop me vegan for health
reasons is really a fascinating one to
me and why people
take those stories and hold it with so
much weight without looking at the the
past and the future
for sure i mean but it's just one more
source it's just one more place where
people are getting that confirmation
bias because it really is all over the
place yes
it's in our families we're getting it
there we're getting it in our religions
we're getting it in our politics we're
getting it in our social group we're
getting it in our you know our the
restaurants the marketing the
advertising so it's just one more place
so my answer is okay so
what does that mean for me and what it
means for me is i'm gonna be the one
who's gonna use my voice in my channel
and my whatever right to espouse what i
think is um helpful for people
um so so that's one thing
um the other thing is at the end of the
day that's all i mean that is literally
all i can control and i'm not going to
be able to control what what what
everybody else is doing yeah so it's
true that people
people do look at those
youtube videos i will say this though i
might disagree a little bit and say
based on what i've read and you know
this is just you know there's lots of
data out there but based on what i've
read
i really do think we are i believe based
on what i have
read that we are more influenced by our
peer group than we are by strangers on
social media so the experience you're
going to have with your mother or your
sister or your coworker is going to
actually be more impactful for you than
a fleeting video you see that you
commented on and maybe it becomes part
of a story that you tell yourself but i
think in the end what really matters is
how we feel in the lives we live and so
what is important and this is a good
segue is again we can't control what our
mother is going to say that our sister's
going to say in our coworker but we can
we can control how we engage with them
and that's a lot of what happens when
people stop being vegan is i was saying
before is that we forget what it was
like before we were vegan
and what that means is how we interact
with the people who are not vegan in our
lives we can be a little judgy we could
be a little you know
judgmental and arrogant and and and even
dismissive and say i don't want to be
around you i mean there's a movement of
people who say i will not have dinner
with my family for
friend peer group whatever because
you're eating animal products we can
talk about that too because i get that i
mean there's something to say there but
to have it as it as a rule
is really problematic for me and so you
think our family and our friends want to
be around someone who's sitting there in
judgment of them and who doesn't want to
be around them that is not going to do
anything for you feeling like you have a
sense of belonging or them feeling like
they want to understand from you because
you're already in a place of judgment
so i would say let's worry no you could
do both you could worry about your
youtube comments but i would say let's
worry about less about that right
let's focus more on those interpersonal
relationships that we have
with our peer group with our with our
cokers
the people we see on the street the
people
in the supermarket it's so easy when we
first become vegan and this is stage one
stage one literally is bearing witness
and being overwhelmed by the amount of
awareness you have that they're
suffering
it's painful it's difficult it's hard
you go to the supermarket you see
everybody buying meat and milk and
everything right and you want to
scream out to everybody like don't you
understand what you're doing right and
that's what we carry with us and that's
what we project out to the world and so
what i'm suggesting is i'm saying this
in a very short way obviously i have the
book to say this is i get it it's
painful totally hear it you need to feel
that and you need to know that's real
and i validate that and what can we do
to manage it so that we can still stay
true to our values but still have
relationships and not walk around
looking at everybody
as a sadistic you know murderer we have
to find a way to engage in a different
way so that we can still stand up and be
proud and say mom this is really hard i
know you're eating that i'm just gonna
step away because it's just painful for
me i love you you taught me to be
compassionate you taught me to be
someone who's discerning and i love you
this isn't about you um but i need to
just step away or hey thanksgiving is
coming and i want to be part of this
because i love you my family can we have
the turkey sit in the kitchen and
everybody can serve themselves and just
have all of the sides on the table
together can we find these ways to
engage with the people in our lives
that's going to go a lot farther and
you're going to feel still connected
they're going to feel
that you still love them because so much
of this is the defensiveness we have
when someone changes
something that's so fundamental
to
who they are but also to the
relationship it's so fundamental so
that's what i'm more interested in is
how do we engage in these interpersonal
relationships that we can stay vegan and
stay joyful yeah i think you make a
really bad point that the most
influential in their lives on whether
they're going to stay vegan is like
who's in their life how they're
navigating relationships in their life
the cultural norms
but i think on top of that if someone
which a lot of people don't have a lot
of vegans in their life so their only
way of connecting with vegans right of
the vegan community is what's online so
what they see online could potentially
influence their themselves being like
adding on top of that stuff that's
already more difficult for them to
navigate so when they see that it's a
little bit like oh okay yeah maybe and
it like it i think i think they're both
influential personally oh and i'm not
denying that it's not but you're but the
way you're making it sound is that
they're just literally falling into
these videos they could click play if
they want or they don't have to yeah i
mean they can go to a diff they can see
what the video says why i stopped being
vegan and now my life is better i mean
you're hitting play like you're looking
for that you can also look for the
videos that say how to stay a joyful
vegan or go find the communities that
are going to be supportive of you and
it's okay if it's online i mean
especially now it's wonderful that we
have so many options to be able to
connect with people online i still do
say in the joyful vegan do you think
that we need to still find ways to
connect with like-minded people in
person
and again not shun the families and
friends who are not vegan and navigate
that too
but i i i totally agree with you i think
it is influential but we have agency in
terms of what we're choosing to listen
to but unfortunately like drama gets
clicks people want people people are
tempted to click on drama way more than
they are on like something like how do i
stay vegan i'm already vegan like how do
i stay being right people are more
likely to click on something that's
drama it's just like within themselves
um but i think you're right like these
are like two separate like conversation
i guess conversations that are molding
together but like to two different
audiences right like there's a group of
people who might be listening who are
vegan and there and that type of
information is so helpful for them right
like how do i navigate a world like
where i'm you know loving and accepting
of everybody but also being proud of
where i stand and there's different
levels of people and how strongly they
feel about being a vegan as well like i
have friends who are um like plant-based
slash vegan but it's really not
something that bothers them if they're
around someone around eating meat like
they would they would never tell someone
and not eat meat around them right and
then there's others who have a more
opposite end of the spectrum of what you
described so it really depends on each
person there's so much nuance and gray
then there's the other topic of like
people who might be listening who aren't
vegan and they're like
how do you respond to this all these
people who had to stop because of this
and so that is interesting to me too in
like something that you just don't hear
like like they're they're seeing videos
like that they're seeing anecdotes and
you're like how like what do you have to
say about that and to me i actually have
a lot to say so that's why i said that
well what i would say to that is then if
you want to stop seeing all those videos
then go watch other videos and the
algorithm will change in your youtube
channel yeah like you were getting the
videos that are com confirming what
you've already been clicking on that's
literally how it works totally so if you
want to get more videos on like how do i
respond to
x yeah xx you know x y and z uh you're
gonna get more of those yeah well i also
have a lot of audience who aren't vegan
at all and so it's just an interesting
conversation the like the
they might be dabbling with being like
hmm i'm interested in being plant-based
but i'm also seeing that maybe it's
healthier if i eat more ancestral or if
i eat more raw dairy or if i eat you
know
grass-fed beef all that stuff and liver
and all these things and so a lot of
people are very confused nutritionally
on like what's healthy and so when you
see anecdotes of people who stop being
vegan it is quite influential and so i
like i like responding to those people
who are on the fence or maybe not even
on the fence but they're just curious
right and they want to hear all the
perspectives which i love i love that
like this podcast is it seems to be
gaining an audience of all different
types of perspectives and so that's why
i'm like i don't want to just address
like okay the people who are already
vegan how do we respond or how do we
keep going or whatever right but also
people who are listening who aren't
vegan totally and thank you for doing
that i mean that's what we we need
people
making that content so that people know
who to go to that they trust and they
can find that information yeah they can
form decisions because that's what it's
about right so you kind of feel like
socially you know friends family members
society at large like what do you feel
about society at large
makes it harder for people or to want to
stay vegan or go vegan or commit
themselves like what it's specifically
about society at large because there's
actually another side that also thinks
that you know society at large is trying
to tell us to be vegan when we actually
need animal foods right yeah so that's
funny let's get into that that's it's
funny because what happens is so the the
idea that we need to consume animal
flesh and fluids right so meat milk
dairy eggs all of it the
the that message has been
ingrained in us since we were young from
our family from our you know from our
from our parents from our the
advertising the school
you know
information that we're given that the
teachers are given from the dairy
industry like in every way we're told
that we should eat as much meat dairy
and eggs as possible
and then
you have someone right and everyone's
like okay that's what we're supposed to
do and then a vegan comes along they're
like stop telling me what to do stop
telling me how to eat and the idea i
think what happens is because
the idea that we should consume as much
meat dairy and eggs as possible is
status quo we forget that it's a bias we
forget that it's bias and we trust
the very people who
you know in the case of the industry
this is obviously not our family members
i'm not a conspiracy theorist so i don't
believe that everyone's the man
everyone's out to get us i don't it's
just that it's ingrained in all of us
and it most of it does come from the
industries that do profit off of
off of our purchasing of these things so
so but we forget that that's actually a
bias because it's status quo and because
it's so prevalent
it's everywhere i mean just
list watch any advertisement that comes
on on youtube tv
radio look at the billboards and the
thing there's in movies i mean just in
every way we are bombarded with these
messages so so then it looks like
veganism is a bias and has an agenda
whereas the other was neutral and that's
that's what i would first again caution
people to to to understand so
so why is it so hard for people because
so many people eat meat because so many
people eat meat i think that is just the
easiest way to say it everybody around
us does the same thing and again we want
to belong but we also just have also
internalized the beliefs that we're
supposed to and that if we don't i mean
i've over the years i mean i've heard
from people
terrified to stop consuming cow's milk
or terrified to not feed their child
cow's milk they're in the state of fear
so i get it like we're all conditioned
to believe those things what i try to do
is unpack that to say you know obviously
the nutrients we need are plant-based
they're not animal-based the reason
there's calcium in cow's milk is because
the cow ate grass and there's calcium in
the grass right i mean technically
speaking but most of the um in most
cases majority of cases 98 of the cases
the animals are just given supplements
and then they're given calcium
supplements so how about skip the middle
animal and just take the calcium
supplements yourself or better yet eat
kale not grass you can eat grass i mean
i guess people are drinking grass
so
so the idea is to help people kind of
shift their understanding and challenge
their own beliefs challenge the beliefs
that they have internalized that have
been you know told by others which is
why yeah get the information out there
you say it's confusing i think it's
confusing because every you know people
who are selling a particular thing have
an agenda but really it's common sense
so i'm not even trying to sell anything
like it's just a mineral found in the
ground cal we don't mine you know cows
we mine minerals like it's literally a
mineral found in the ground that's all
of it that's the protein that's the iron
the calcium b12 is the only nutrient
that we need that's not plant-based but
it's not animal animal-based either it's
bacteria based so and again we give
supplements we give b12 supplements to
cattle before we kill them
so so that's just challenging our own
belief system but it's hard to do that
when everybody around you is not only
telling you that you have to do this but
you need to do this or you're going to
be sick
yeah and then there's also just the way
people will respond like to you if
something comes up oh it must be because
you're vegan but if something comes up
when you're not vegan it's like oh i'm
so sorry that that happened to you to me
like a really good example would be like
miscarriage or something like if someone
has had a miscarriage like oh maybe it's
because you're vegan but then if you're
not vegan you have a miscarriage no one
would ever dare say oh maybe it's
because you eat animal food for sure you
know for sure but you know we're guilty
that two is vegans and and i think you
were talking about expectations before
we have expectations of ourself that are
unrealistic we have expectations of each
other we have expectations of vegans we
have expectations of non-vegans
expectations get us into trouble every
single time so what you know i've been
told over the years i mean it's
ridiculous i've seen vegans say no you
didn't get sick you're vegan you don't
get sick vegans say that to me yeah and
you know you don't stop becoming you
don't stop being human when you become
vegan it's it's utterly ridiculous so
the expectations we have of each other
and that we're all supposed to represent
some perfect
beingness is wrong and i mean the most
heartbreaking letters i have gotten are
from people who you know whether it's
being they had a cold and everyone was
like you know giving them you know shite
for for that um but also depending on
what you look like and what your body is
and or your skin and that to me is
heartbreaking that people who who
think they don't present perfect feel
that they can't say that they're vegan
because they think they're a poor
representation that to me is the most
heartbreaking thing so again i can't
control what the non-vegans are thinking
doing saying or the vegans but i would
just say um we need to
just understand that we are as diverse a
population as any other population and
we are still human and we're gonna
look different be different and feel
different but
it's
it's not my job to prove that veganism
is amazing it's it's my job to just live
who be who i am and if that is
attractive to you and you want to know
more i'm going to tell you i'm not going
to make you any promises i'm going to
tell you that you are definitely going
to still get sick i'm going to tell you
you might have a heart attack i'm going
to tell you that you might get cancer
i'm not going to tell you that like
first conversation
that'd be like really annoying but what
i will tell you is that if you stop
eating animal products you are not going
to be eating any dietary cholesterol i'm
going to tell you that if you're eating
no animal products you are going to eat
be eating a lot less saturated fat
especially animal-based saturated fat
which is actually more problematic than
plant-based saturated fat i'm going to
tell you that you're not going to be
consuming any animal protein you're not
going to be consuming any lactase you're
not going to be consuming any lactose
you're not going to be consuming any
anything that the data show are
problematic and are
risk factors for the heart disease the
cancer so i'm not going to tell you that
you'll never have you know a problem but
i'm going to tell you that you are
really eliminating all of many most of
the risk factors to get less likely much
less likely so okay i can tell you that
the rest of it are you going to be fat
you're going to be skinny is your is
your you know was your skin going to be
perfect i don't know how do you eat and
what do you eat and the way you eat when
you first become vegan is very different
than how you continue to eat you learn
things you grow you learn to cook better
you start craving things you never
craved before you stop wanting all of
the fat and salt that was in like highly
processed meat dairy products because
your palate is cleaner because you're
not consuming all of that stuff so it
changes and it morphs and this is the
point is that being vegan is a journey
it's not the destination it's not the
end it's the beginning of a new way of
seeing the world and engaging with it
i love that that's too i never said that
before
little mark on that specific one pull it
out
so specifically i might title this
episode how to stop being vegan because
there's something about it like what
specifically just anecdotally right if
we're taking it from the devil's
advocate you're like okay this is what
you need to do if you're going to end up
not staying vegan what would those
things be that's very good that's very
good sure i can yeah i mean i could
rattle some things off
sure absolutely i mean that's literally
what the joyful vegan is obviously in
the positive way because the joyful
vegan talks about 10 stages of what
happens when you stop eating animals
and it not only gives you the name for
the thing that i know you're
experiencing because we all tend to
it also gives you the thing you need to
protect against
not using that as a way to stop being
vegan and also stop being joyful because
that's a big part of this as well
so ways to stop being vegan okay
um
just be um angry and judgmental and
forget that you once didn't know as well
um
look at everybody else is doing harm and
you're the one who's doing everything
right
see yourself as separate from everybody
else
don't um engage with your family and and
and judge them by this one criterion
veganism rather than by all the other
criteria that
we tend to take into account when we
have relationships with people how good
they are how kind they are how generous
they are how
how
helpful they are how all those things
but but just use that one criterion and
look through only that one lens to judge
the world and everybody around you
don't ask for what you want be meek and
uh self-effacing and
not you know rock the boat at all and
when you do rock the boat make sure
you're really heavy-handed about it or
just don't rock the boat at all and just
stay back in the closet and when a
server comes to you and says what would
you like to eat you say
i don't want to be a pain but like um
can you i don't know can you can i do i
have anything that's be that be meek as
opposed to just hi i'm vegan can you
just let me know what you have that
doesn't have any animal products so
don't do that don't do that
um
don't um find a community of people
don't ever say you're vegan because
you're afraid of however the people are
going to take it
um
don't ever
have a conversation with someone who
challenges you make sure you just keep
thinking about them the way you're
already thinking about them judgmentally
you're right they're wrong and don't
have a conversation with them and um
don't try anything new don't do anything
new just stay stuck in uh in kind of you
know just a stagnant
sad angry place
that was a wonderful list and it's not
all anger and it's not all sadness but
it is it is separation it's that i'm
better because it's not just that i'm
different it's that i'm better
and everybody else is doing something
wrong and i'm doing it right
and that's what i mean about
understanding that like where we were
and and i think
so one of the things i said just then
was don't say that you're vegan it's
also like don't tell your story in
telling your story
you're actually first of all crafting
this
this true narrative for yourself i mean
i don't think a lot of vegans really sit
down because i mean i've heard from
people who say like i'm afraid of
someone just asking me like why i'm
vegan like what should i say and i'm
like well say the truth true like why
are you vegan but should i say this
because they're they might be more
influenced by that and should i say this
and should i use statistics and just say
why speak from your heart people respond
to that and i don't think a lot of i
think the feakens because we have so
much pressure we put on ourselves and
we're put on by others that we're
supposed to be experts in every single
field i mean i joke that you know
there's the expectation we're supposed
to be experts in you know the culinary
arts and anthropology and nutrition and
psychology and sociology and animal
husbandry and like history and like you
know just relax a little bit and just
speak from your heart
and tell your story so in telling your
story not only are you speaking from
your heart and you're really owning your
story
someone else could potentially identify
with you but you're also reiterating
that you once weren't vegan and now you
are because there's a notion people
think like people ask me like were you
always vegan no i mean that's ridiculous
i grew up in the 70s in new jersey like
i mean of course i didn't grow up vegan
you know from a working-class family who
ate everything that walked in flint and
swam and flew like that's what we did
and so when i say no of course they ate
animal and they go really yes i'm not
like a separate being from you i
can totally identify with what your
struggles are
that's what makes people want to know
more and engage with us and have a
conversation with us so be it's not even
being humble it's just
being
just remembering and then telling it so
when someone says why are you vegan well
because you know like if you're eating
animal products it's really bad for the
environment it's really bad for the
animals it's really bad for your health
bye
like who wants like no like that's just
not gonna like what okay why are you
vegan because i didn't know when i was
eating animals that i was contributing
to things that were like so painful for
me to even look at and when i finally
looked i was like i can't be part of
this and so it's been wonderful since i
have been but you know i get it they go
what wait you have those feelings too i
didn't know that's what i'm talking
about yes for sure i love when you
mentioned the meekness aspect too
because i do get emails um from you know
family members a lot of times it's like
mothers or fathers who are like you know
i don't get a lot of support raising our
family plant-based or vegan and you know
i don't really know how to stand up for
myself like people are saying things
this or that about the way we raise our
kids you know and i'm like look are you
guys healthy like how's your family
doing how are your kids doing oh they're
amazing they're thriving we're good and
i'm like just stand up for yourself be
confident and loving at the same time
there's a way to be confident and loving
and respectful all at the same time you
know you don't have to be nasty with
your opinions you don't have and
actually that'll make it worse and you
don't also have to cower in a corner and
just let someone talk over you and
you're like oh you're right you're right
when you know they're not right like you
know that your family's thriving and be
confident and firm but loving at the
same time and that is the best way for
people to also feel confident because
they'll be like okay they do know what
they're doing and their family's doing
well and sometimes people just need a
little reassurance and being confident
is also like goes a long way i think
with family members
absolutely 100
and we have to know where we end and
someone else begins if we say i'm vegan
and someone else says oh my god stop
trying to convert me
you're pretty clear that you weren't
like you know where you stood you know
what you said
and i do think that confidence and this
communication and this is another
element of the
not staying vegan is about our
communication
methods and i personally believe that
our communication with someone below
like begins before we even speak to them
so it's not just a matter of when we're
talking and verbalizing that the
communication begins it's what i'm
thinking about you before i even start
speaking speaking and what i think about
me before i start speaking so intention
bringing intention to every moment and
every relationship and every
conversation so if i'm coming to you
and my and and i'm already just
defensive let's see let's see what would
be a scenario uh
you're
a friend and uh or a friend of a friend
right you're a co-worker or whatever and
you and i'm already like oh they're
they're a meat eater i i can't even deal
with them i know they're gonna like ask
me about this and i'm so sick of getting
the protein question so fine i'm gonna
say hi to them and tell them i'm vegan
like you know that comes out right and
that person asks the protein question
you're already armed
you're already defensive you're already
annoyed right because okay we're all
right of the project how about the
intention is this is an opportunity to
have a conversation about something that
might be new to them and they're asking
me a question that yeah i've heard a
million times but it's the first time
they're asking it to me at that moment
in this place that is the first time
we're having this experience together
and so if my intention in going into
every situation is i'm going to be a
vessel for information if they happen to
ask whatever right but i'm looking at
them as a kind good person who might be
curious
and i'm going to show up as a good kind
person who's also curious and that is a
very different interaction than one that
you would have if you're already like
you've drawn a conclusion
yeah i mean going it your your
perspective about it makes all the
difference you know totally and the way
that you present yourself and then
there's also the factor i think that
didn't get brought up in your wonderful
list of eating junk food all the time
just eating really unwell and just
saying look because it's just because
it's vegan a lot of times people will
say like look you know i was actually
you know more intentional with the way i
ate before i went vegan then i went
vegan then i just turned you end up
turning into like oh as long as it says
that it's vegan then it's good but that
is actually just going to set you up for
failure long term like i really do
believe like i said in the earlier part
of the episode about like you want to
feel well and that is a very big
motivating factor for a lot of people to
be able to stay plant-based and vegan
and so i think eating well and being
intentional with the way that you eat
lots of fruits and vegetables like
listening to the physicians and the
plant-based nutritionists and doctors
that are able to like give advice that
help you learn how to like well plan
your diet because that's going to help
you feel your best long term and like
you said things are going to come up you
know no one feels perfect but going to
the heart of like how my overall my
wellness and realizing that like feeling
well isn't just about food like that's a
small component to your wellness because
you can eat really well but if you're
not sleeping
and if you don't have good relationships
and you're super stressed all day and
you're not getting sunshine or taking a
vitamin d supplement if you don't live
in a place where you can get adequate
sunshine like then you're not going to
feel well and so all those things
playing a factor and like don't be so
quick to like jump to the conclusion it
must be because i'm vegan just because
your social peers and your pressures the
culture at large of what you're talking
about is telling you so that it must be
that for sure what is that the
availability bias i think like that's
the idea that like something that's just
really recent
is that must be true right so a lot of
people if they you know they make a
change in their diet two days later
they're like oh i'm sick it must be
because i stopped eating animal products
like that it doesn't really work that
way
like there's probably other factors and
it's okay to consider it as a factor but
you you absolutely have to look at all
the factors and there's also like just
something really simple like eating
enough calories absolutely you know like
because when you change your diet like
that it is gonna take some time
navigating and figuring out what you're
replacing with you can't just take out
the animal foods you got to replace it
with the same amount of calories of
healthy plant foods you know because i
once had a friend who was like okay i
tried i tried it for three days
i was so tired and i'm like what did you
eat he's like i eat like just salad and
i'm like
well you can't just eat salad like like
well what was even the salad he's like
lettuce and carrots tomatoes and i'm
like did you have avocado what about
like some garbanzo beans something like
and you can't just eat lettuce and
vegetables all day you know and so a lot
of times people just really don't know
how to navigate it and this is more
getting into like plant-based eating
right because like there's different
there's a difference between someone who
has like an ethical stance um to what
you're just described and then there's
also people who are wanting to eat more
plants and get more plant-based and
maybe they start out eating
vegan or plant-based for their health
and then long-term over time they start
finding these other reasons as well and
it's all just synchronistic and you
realize there are so many reasons to eat
plant-based that it's like undeniable at
least for me you know like because i
sometimes get questions like do you ever
consider stopping being vegan and one of
the reasons i get those questions is
because of x vegan videos or
social media influencers and
i'm in that realm of being online so
people do like look at me and be like
well look at all these people stop being
bigger i see these stories like are you
gonna stop being vegan and like you said
we shouldn't just have our
faith in humanity just like looking at a
social media person right but my
response is like no i literally have
no that no there's no way i'm gonna stop
being vegan and you know i've been being
for 15 years and thriving seeing my
health just take off from where i was
before to now eating abundantly and
fueling my body in such a way where i
feel amazing and then on top of it
learning all the other reasons that are
because for me i started out as like a
plant-based eater it wasn't like for the
animals i didn't have the connection to
the animals i was never an animal lover
like you said like growing up and that's
something i also say that i'm like you
don't have to be an animal lover to be
vegan because i growing up i i didn't
really care about animals that much and
part of that could have been just my
personality or maybe the way i was
raised right i didn't want to see harm
to them though you know that's the thing
is that once i was pointed out that fact
that like
look you might not care that much like
when your family dog passes away because
i remember i was actually walking along
this street with my friend and i got a
phone call from my mom in high school
and she told me that john luke died yeah
dog's name was jean luke
and because my dad was a big star trek
fan and i was like oh okay like you know
just didn't it didn't impact me that
much and then my friend who was a huge
animal lover started crying and i was
like why are you crying i'm not crying
like for some reason i just didn't have
that same connection and now my friend
who was crying on that phone call um
next to me she's vegan now too which is
so cool um but anyway so i made that
connection later where i had watched a
gary yourofsky video
the best speech you'll ever hear that
video just shook me to my core i
couldn't believe that i never cared
before you know because it was one of
those things where when i was eating
plant-based i would get questions like
do you care that i'm eating meat in
front of you i'm like i literally could
care less like i'm just doing this for
me you know i'm just doing this for my
health i don't care about the illness
and part of that was just maybe my dad
who you see like paleo and a lot of meat
it was like cool to eat meat it was cool
to eat steak and it was just cool and
you just don't think about the animals
but then after watching that i'm like
wow and i think my heart was more open
because i already was eating plant-based
certainly yeah and so that happens a lot
so for people who are listening who are
maybe like dabbling willing to eat
plant-based more and maybe they're not
there with the ethics and they're kind
of like what are you talking about i
really don't care if there's turkey on
the table like everyone's on their
journey in their own little their own
stage right and there could even be an
ethical vegan that still doesn't care if
there's a turkey on the table like it
just depends on where people are at and
and how they feel but i'm kind of
rambling but basically i think that the
factor of taking taking care of your
body nourishing yourself well will go
such a long way to help you feel your
best and then for me seeing just like
the way it has played out in my family
how healthy and thriving my kids are
like none of my kids have ever needed to
go to the hospital they all are just so
healthy my husband's thriving and we're
just like doing so well and i also just
take the advice of experts and
nutritionists and
plant-based doctors and a lot of times
like you said people get caught up in
just looking at influencers and
youtubers
and instead of actually going to the
source of like look who are these
physicians and these doctors and
nutritionists who have been doing this
for decades how are they eating what are
they recommending how are they helping
their patients and so all that plays a
role in accordance with getting that
information with you and all the things
you just mentioned about the social
aspects do you agree for sure 100
yeah for sure i think we talked about
that really well the cultural norms
the um like what about the breaching
your own values and sabotaging their own
goals in the process process what's that
well that's what's interesting because
that's what we were talking about i
think earlier where
when someone
you know makes a decision let's say
they're stopping being vegan
they they don't couch it in terms of
i don't care anymore
they couch it in terms of the things
they have to use to say like i have no
control
i would do it differently if i could but
i but i can't that's what i'm talking
about about about breaching our own
goals but that's really kind of the
the framing that i use for all of this
whether it's you know becoming vegan and
at least considering it or and again
when i say becoming vegan i don't mean
this in a join this club and here's the
goal and you get a badge and this is
like the end it literally is for me the
manifestation of the values we have and
so the question we have to ask ourselves
is not and this is something for vegans
to hear too who are listening whose
advocacy might be
go vegan the advocacy might include
saying to the public go vegan i would
say to you stop saying that
because not only do people first of all
don't respond to being told what to do
and i know you're saying it's just a
slogan
no but that's the truth yeah you can't
tell and you cannot tell people what to
do
but there's another kind of more you
know obviously i'm the more
psychological part of this which is
vegan isn't a value no one hears the
word vegan they know kind of what it
means but it doesn't it's not a value if
i said to you be kind you that's a value
and you go oh that that that taps into
my own value you say that that taps into
a value i have you say be compassionate
you be thoughtful that taps into values
i have i want to be a good kind
compassionate person you say go vegan
there's nothing there
there's no value called vegan
so what we have to do is speak to values
in people
not this
means to the values that's what veganism
means to the end the end is to be as
compassionate and healthy as we can be
that's the end that's the goal the goal
isn't to be as vegan as i could be that
doesn't even mean anything yeah and that
but that's how a lot of advocates frame
it and the public go i don't know what
you're saying like they're not even
resisting they're just like i don't even
know what you're talking about yeah
because it doesn't resonate with them it
doesn't resonate with any frame that
exists within them but if you say
um and again i'm not saying do it like
this because i i have never said go
vegan in the 20 some years i've been
doing this work and i you know i've
heard from a lot of people who've become
vegan from my work but i've never said
go vegan all i do is create the frame
give the information and people then
decide what to do people are kind of
smart enough to know that if i'm saying
when i ate animals i was contributing to
a system of violence that i was not
comfortable with that i was paying
people to hurt animals and to do things
to them that i would never be able to do
myself
people hear that and go okay that's
really resonating with me and then the
logical conclusion is well i don't want
to be part of that therefore i'm going
to stop and never i'm going to be vegan
whatever right the point is we need to
speak to people's values and not the
manifestation of those values because
vegan is
the means to the end not the end itself
the end is compassion and wellness
not veganism and that i think is a
distinction that a lot of
people
you know whether you're vegan or not i
think they they really think that being
vegan is the goal it's the badge you
wear it's the thing you aspire to that's
not what we're aspiring to and if we as
advocates want to inspire people i think
people are going to be more inclined to
hear that they want to be compassionate
kind healthy people not
this thing called vegan it's just a word
that reflects the manifestation of the
values that we hold really dearly all of
us do yeah wow i'm so glad that you said
that i normally have i've never heard
someone put it that way but it's such a
great
um way to explain it because when you
really break it down it's not just the
like go vegan what it is is the reasons
behind it so while i was saying you know
all the health benefits i've received
and how thriving my family is on top of
it there's the fact that like to me it
just makes logical sense to not support
animal suffering because it there's
nothing appetizing about one about
seeing an animal suffer or be
dismembered and skinned and all that
factors into my reasons why i'm vegan
right because it helps explain it it
helps explain it like okay why am i
feeling this compassion
towards the animals because when i look
at it and it's like
no there's nothing appetizing about
there's a reason why we don't see it
social media influencers are not going
to be posting video pictures of like
animals being skinned dismembered
there's a reason why no one wants to see
it you know we know the conviction we
already have within our hearts and so
it's just the manifestation of how it
plays out it's interesting because so we
were talking about willful blindness
before which i think is a really really
big one again willful blindness is the
is the way we try and reconcile the
cognitive dissonance we have if we don't
look don't tell me i don't want to see
don't tell me i don't want to know don't
show me i don't want to know right so we
are protecting ourselves from the thing
that we know which is interesting to me
i actually see i'm i tend to be
optimistic and i tend to see that as a
sign of optimism because they know that
if they look or see
they're going to be compelled to do
something different
so
we have them when i say we haven't like
you're already a kind good person what
you're doing is not reflecting the
values you already have so i'm not
telling you to do anything different
than listen to your own heart i'm not
telling you to do this because i'm
telling you to do it don't listen to me
i'm not telling you to live according to
my values i'm urging you to live
according to your own values and if you
didn't think you weren't living if you
if you already thought you were you
wouldn't have to say don't tell me so
that willful blindness is actually we
think it's protecting us it's actually
hindering us because it's only when
you're willing to look and you've
mentioned before it happens for
different people at different times once
you stop eating animal products you tend
to be more able to look because you're
not then hung up on the guilt you have
because you're still eating them so how
whatever encourages you inspires you to
stop eating the animal products or it
might come from the trigger of like
something you saw or something you bore
witness to the point is
once you're not anymore
you're actually liberated from all of
this tension of trying to like avoid
seeing things and and and not feel bad
and like not want to talk to people and
not want to talk about you don't do any
of that anymore once you just let go and
you have to be willing to look but it's
literally the looking that frees you
that liberates you so this willful
blindness is very personal it's very
self-driven but of course it's as we
talked about it's other driven it's our
families who don't want us to change
because they want us just the way we are
because we're familiar because they know
how to interact with us right they're
not they're not bad people because they
get defensive because we've become vegan
it's that they don't know how to respond
they don't know what it means they don't
know what to do and especially i'm about
to go on a rant especially because
by the time we come to our families and
friends and say that we're vegan we've
processed a lot
we've thought about it a lot or
plant-based doesn't even matter we've
thought about it we've looked in some
information we've learned some things
we've watched videos we've watched
documentaries we've read books by the
time we go to our family and friends
we've processed it and then we say to
them we're vegan and they go well why
are you doing it that's ridiculous you
can't do that and you and you're like
fine you never listen to me see you
don't even understand you don't care and
it's like you just told them like
give them the space and the time to also
navigate this because mostly people who
are resistant to you becoming vegan it
does change over time you just have to
understand it's going to take them some
time as well right so
they're resistant to us changing because
i liken it to a dance like if you're
dancing the waltz with someone your
entire life and all of a sudden you
start doing the foxtrot they're going to
be like what do you do i don't know
where you're going like i don't even
know those steps and i don't know how to
keep up with you and you're like no but
the foxtrot is really great
and not only is the foxtrot really great
it's the waltz is bad and now the person
we used to dance with goes wait so now
i'm also just bad like i am not even
like you don't even want to dance with
me because now what i'm doing is wrong
right so you see this dynamic versus i'm
gonna dance over here would you like to
dance with me and you can keep dancing
there and i'll join you over here but
let's navigate this together we have to
understand that when we shift the dance
steps people are forced to do it as well
and people don't like change
so the willful blind is the self-imposed
self-directed it's other directed
they don't want us to change and then of
course the industries who want us to
keep buying products but you're talking
about social media influencers who
wouldn't put out these these videos the
industries literally these ag gag laws
they're called where they're literally
making it a crime to document what
happens on factory farms or just what
happens on farms and one state after
another has been trying to make it
illegal to document and put people in
prison for quite literally raising
awareness and every single one of them
is being
is being completely reversed because
it's completely unconstitutional right
the point is there are so many forces
and factors who are trying to keep us
blind and trying to keep us
um ignorant and our job is to at least
just be open that that is my hope for
anybody is just never say never and just
be open
but again it's not being open to my
beliefs it's being open to your own
beliefs that's where you're going to
find the liberation and the truth yeah
that's all that we can ask like just
being open even to this topic and
conversation at hand because anyone
who's listening and just kind of
battling but like we need to eat animal
foods to be healthy really ask yourself
if you don't want to see it happening
before you eat these foods every time
like if you're like not itching to see
it you're like i really would rather not
ask if this is actually even something
we're supposed to be eating because you
know there's a reason why
slaughterhouses don't have glass walls
you know there's like that saying that
if slaughterhouses have glass walls
everyone would be vegan because like you
said you know they're trying to hide it
because it's not appetizing and the
foods that are best for us
look beautiful to us in their natural
state brightly colored plant foods those
are the foods that we're supposed to be
eating that is the way that we're
designed to thrive and so if you're
looking at it and going well but i but i
need this to be healthy like really ask
yourself if that's really really true if
you do not want to see what's happening
to the animals and you have to
disassociate yourself from it
to feel comfortable with it yeah i mean
i'll warn people if they watch a carrot
being torn out of the ground it could be
pretty violent so
i'm warning you
but that's the point is that no one has
any problem with seeing vegetables
harvested no we don't have to have
different words for it we don't have to
have laws against watching people
harvest vegetables we don't need the
euphemisms about it we don't we
absolutely don't yeah because there's
something about these specific animal
foods that people feel more comfortable
eating like grass-fed free-range
ethically sourced right all that stuff
makes people feel comfortable with the
the animal foods that they're buying and
saying well look this is the way it has
to be
um and really getting and at least the
animals suffer less so like even just
the fact that you want the animals to
suffer less shows you that you have
compassion within your heart that you
don't you don't want them to suffer
that's right so really getting to that
heart of asking yourself like truly why
do you feel that you need to give your
power away to these animals animals to
be able to be healthy
is really fascinating yeah it's
interesting because i think that there's
an element of like even the industry
they're like they're aware that we're
compassionate that's why they change all
the words that's why they use the
marketing language they do because they
know that we're good kind compassionate
people and so they they're they're
making sure that we still believe that
about ourselves yeah and that's what you
were saying goes back to what we said
earlier is that we have to believe that
we're good people so instead of changing
our behavior we have to change our
beliefs about our behavior and of course
we're going to say i'm not causing harm
and in fact some of the things we do is
more than just say we're not causing
harm we actually frame it so that we're
actually helping the animals there's a
narrative that says if we didn't kill
them
i don't even know what a
a lion is gonna kill them or they'll be
like we have to milk the cow or else the
milk others will be full not realizing
that like look the cow isn't making milk
just to make milk the cow's making milk
for her baby that was taken from her so
we can take all of her milk like just
imagine if the milk carton instead of
having that picture of the happy cow and
the baby cow next to each other smiling
in a grassy field like okay maybe you're
getting grass-fed let's just say you're
for sure getting that like free-range
grass-fed milk right but imagine if the
picture on that carton didn't have that
happy picture of the cow but actually
just had the picture of the end result
of like the cow being strung upside down
and blood dripping from their neck
because they all end up that way like
you're not buying from places where
they're like we just let the cows live
in the old age until they're 23 years
old you know no that is not what happens
no matter how nice these farms are it's
not sustainable there's no way to
sustain the planet on the way that this
idealistic way even if like let's say if
we're dabbling even if you let these
cows last as long live as long as they
want even if you let the baby cow stay
with the mom and have some of the milk
right that is not a sustainable business
model for farmers they cannot sustain
themselves in that way and pay the bills
and feed the world even if right like
that's just even getting into that
aspect as well let alone the topic of if
we should be using their bodies for
us when we don't need it but if you're
going to even talk about that it is
literally not sustainable it's not
something we can do and not something
that even happens for sure and the point
is this is what we tell ourselves and
that's why it's so powerful and we all
reinforce it we all say yep exactly
i'm doing i'm doing it for the animals i
mean the absurdity that we actually do i
mean i talk in the book about something
you know i don't know if you remember
the commercials but there was these you
know starkist tuna commercials where it
was literally a tuna at the bottom of
the sea who was trying to hook himself
and ever you know the whole sorry
charlie like that was a fish trying to
hook himself and every time he failed
and so the idea like literally is this
narrative we tell ourselves is that
they're sacrificing themselves for us
they're dying for us as if they're
somehow these you know martyrs who are
dying because they know that we're going
to eat them or we're doing them a favor
so that's what's so interesting it's not
just that it's healthy for me it's
actually that we frame it so that we say
it's better for the animals that's the
stuff where you know if that's what
we're telling ourselves i would just
suggest that we step back and say do i
really believe that i mean do i really
believe that even before we get into the
whys and the wherefores that it's that
it's not possible because you know
exactly cows have to be impregnated in
order to provide milk and farmers are
not altruist they're not doing this
because they're philanthropists i'm not
saying that farmers are bad people i'm
saying they're not doing this because
they're charities they're doing this
they're not they're not like they're not
milking the cow because they care about
the cows and they're doing it for a
charitable reason but the way people
talk about it is you'd think they
believed that they're doing it because
it's their business model and and no
good business person would keep
the animals in a way where they're not
going to be able to make profit but
they're just throwing money at them for
their medical care for their food for
their water for their shelter that's not
a business model and that's what's again
so interesting is that we have to keep
finding fault with the person who shows
up who's vegan or just shows up and says
here's what's really true you're biased
you have an agenda do you not think they
have an agenda like again it's not
saying it's evil i'm just saying that's
their business model so we just
lie to ourselves and we're letting
everybody else lie to us and indeed
we're giving away our power and we're
not living according i think that's how
this started we're not living according
to our own values we are quite literally
squandering our own values right so what
about people who are like well but i go
to the farm there are people who will go
to like local farms and like i see it
and they're more
sustainable they're grass-fed and you
know the baby animals stay with the moms
and you know it's all good and
sustainable what are your thoughts on
that like how do you respond how how do
you respond to that i would say babies
who stay with their moms before they're
killed it's a low bar
versus babies who don't stay with their
moms who are killed i mean that's such a
low bar can we raise the bar right so we
have these bars where we're like but you
know humane slaughter is better than
non-humane slaughter i mean there's a
whole conversation around like there's
no one really making sure that there's
humane slaughter laws that are followed
but aside from that like isn't
s slaughter pretty low bar so what about
a higher bar which is no slaughter what
if the bar were no slaughter then i
would say
now let's measure it what are your
thoughts on people who
think okay
well either extreme
either sides if getting too extreme is
just not good why don't we do somewhere
in the middle what about just backyard
hens backyard eggs
you know and just i'm doing the best
that i can and
you know just a little bit of animal
foods and getting it from the best
source that i can get like what are your
thoughts on that yeah so i mean i mean
back to what i said you know
fewer animal products is better than
more animal products so i am
we we're human beings we change slowly i
do the 30-day vegan challenge and i
recommend because i do think it's a
really good way to like really recognize
habits and change the habits but not
everybody does it that way
some people do it by doing it much more
slowly i mean again even if you do the
third diving challenge you can still
find what works for you in the end the
point is whatever we do that is moving
in the direction of the values we say we
have is a good thing you want to eat
fewer animal products fewer animal
products is going to be better you want
to have lower cholesterol fewer animal
products is going to be better you want
to have lower blood pressure et cetera
et cetera you want to not you want to
you want to really try and reflect the
values of compassion for animals that
you have and you can do it with meat but
you can't do it with eggs then do it
with meat right it's the thing i have
said four decades where people say to me
well i could give up everything but i
can't give up
usually cheese i could give up
everything
i really could i admire what you're
doing i really want to do it i could
give up everything but i don't think i
could give up cheese and i said what are
you eating now
and they say
well everything
and cheese and meat and i said well i'm
sorry so you're doing nothing at all
because you think you have to do
everything
as opposed to
just do something right so the idea that
we do nothing at all because we have to
do everything it's paralyzing so don't
do nothing because you can't do
everything do something anything so
anything you do that's in service of the
thing that you want to reach that's in
service of the gold that you want to
attain
is a good thing yeah period full stop
yep so the idea is there's no extreme
it's black and white why would you do
nothing
stop eating meat and fine eat your
cheese and i know it's going to happen
you're going to realize that you're
finding other choices and finding other
options and you're feeling good and
you're lowering all of your animal fat
and you're lowering all of your animal
production you're going to start to feel
good you're going to start to look at
products and say i could actually try
some of these cheeses because now you
freed yourself up and created space for
something new but to hold on to
everything because you think you have to
because you just want to keep holding
onto this one thing it's self-defeating
and it's completely illogical yeah i
think it it can be intimidating for
people sometimes to do all or nothing
and it just depends on the personality
i'm i'm i was so an all all-in type of
person as soon as i realized i was all
in overnight plant-based overnight told
my then boyfriend who's now my husband
when we were 19 years old and i'm like
babe i'm going vegan i didn't know the
difference at the time between like
fish-based or vegan and he's like what
are you talking about i'm like nope no
meat no eggs he's like you're not gonna
eat milk i'm like nope none of it it was
just overnight it was such a no-brainer
easy thing for me but that's not how it
is for everybody and some people do need
to take it slower and sometimes this
notion of like you have to either be all
vegan like you said the label of vegan
or not even try at all sometimes can
just intimidate people and that they
don't even try at all that's right don't
do nothing because you can't do
everything do something anything start
there yeah
absolutely and then there's the factor
of getting into the details of you know
even the ethics of something like having
backyard eggs right like
if we're getting into that specifically
i get questions like that sometimes like
well what about
like i'm just having the eggs in my in
from my backyard from like a hen that i
got
or chickens that i got but a lot of
times people don't realize like where
did that chicken come from like the
chicken came from likely a hatchery
where they're still killing the males um
and then the way that chickens were bred
to have so many eggs that they wouldn't
naturally
you know like we have wild chickens on
our property and sometimes they'll be
like you should eat the eggs and they're
probably like i don't think you
understand like the wild chickens are
not just laying eggs all over the place
like like these eggs that you see on
these commercials and what you think
chickens are supposed to be doing
um so that is an interesting competition
not realizing that chickens in the wild
don't really
lay near as many eggs as what the egg
industry has bred them to be so just the
factor of how we look at animals as like
for our use and breeding them in a way
to use them for our use and if we shift
our mindset about it and then there's
the factor of how sometimes drawing
lines is really helpful for a lot of
people like so for some people might be
like well i'm just gonna eat eggs from
my backyard but now that you're eating
eggs you're at a restaurant you're like
well
it's just i'll just have the one of the
restaurant like i don't know where that
egg came from but you know i eat eggs
now so it's okay whereas for some people
it's like that line that clear line is
really really helpful you know what i'm
saying the difference yeah you bring up
a good point and you have the advantage
of being in a place where you see wild
chickens not most people most people
don't right but i would say look at the
wild birds in your backyard look at the
robins look at the pigeons like look at
the jays like
they don't legs every day so just kind
of understand that these are animals who
lay eggs for a reason they're females
like we are and we all drop our eggs
when they're not fertilized and we don't
have any use for them so if there's no
fertilization there's not going to be a
baby we just drop the eggs out of our
body because it's just unnecessary
that's what the eggs are there for
so so and obviously
yeah and the fact that we've had so many
chickens on our property and never see
them like they're literally no we do not
have just these
wild eggs exactly the only island
of all these eggs there's only 30
chickens on our property but they're
wild chickens right it was only one time
when it was like the chicken had laid
eggs that she was like clearly having
babies because she would go and sit on
it it was like it was very clearly like
for her babies
it's not just like oh all these extra
eggs because they're watching no this is
not how it works in the wild in nature
we as humans have bred them and used
them and exploited them to such a big
degree we think animals are here for us
so we're just going to do whatever we
can to get the maximum amount out of
them
and then think that's just how it is
always but that's just not how it is
that's right that's right and so that's
our that's the due diligence that we
have to do and we have to really
understand that
and and so
so to answer your question specifically
so it's it is about understanding that
you're supporting the industry someone
say i might say i don't care you know
but like you are supporting the
hatcheries as you said and we are
supporting um the breeding of these
animals because most backyard hens are
going to be the breeds that have been
basically made into little frankenstein
monsters to just produce and their
bodies can't really sustain what their
what their poor systems have to have to
endure
it's also intention
i you know if you have hens who were
rescued and your intention is to give
them a life the way you would give any
animal a life for the duration of their
lives and you're there to give them care
and food and you'll be there at the end
of their life that is a different
intention than i have chickens because i
want their eggs we make different
decisions based on the reasons we we
have right and so what it means is if
someone has backyard hens who when those
females stop dropping her eggs and she
will
you might make a decision to say well
i'm gonna you know either kill her
myself or send her to slaughter or
whatever i just don't care i'll let her
die whatever it is right that's
different than i have hens who they're
rescued and they happen to drop eggs
because that's what females do
so i want to just put that out there as
intention as well because and then there
are some people who have backyard
chickens who they would never kill or
sell to slaughter and they do eat their
eggs
again whether they're vegan or not the
people like they eat their eggs fine
there's that's i think one of the
greater areas for me versus like you you
can't have a goat and you can't have a
cow and you can't have a sheep produce
milk without a baby and without taking
her milk like you can't you can't get
away from that with chickens you can i'm
not advocating this but i'm saying that
you know
it's one of those things where like if
you're vegan and in every other way
you're vegan but like you want to eat
the reproductive system you know output
of a
chicken okay like that's your
prerogative i do think and i'm not a fan
i typically am not a fan of slippery
slope arguments but i do think there's a
slippery slope argument because i do
think it's very easy to compartmentalize
that because again we're really good at
willful blindness and we're really good
at saying well my the eggs that i saw
this morning for my chickens are good
i'm sure these are fine and they called
them free range right so that's where i
think it gets to be slippery slope
argument but
but the point is that's not what the
issue is for most people yeah the issue
for most people is that they're buying
eggs 98 of which are factory farm-raised
the chickens they're not there's no we
have no physiological need for chickens
eggs like we have no physiological need
for robin's eggs we just don't have a
physiological need for them and so
they're not only not good for us they're
harming animals they're harming the
environment the amount of waste that
farm animals who are raised for our
consumption whether that's their milk or
their eggs or their flesh is
millions of pounds we're talking about
millions and millions and millions of
pounds of waste a year that is coming
from these systems it is destroying
rivers it is destroying the environment
it is not good for the animals we don't
have a physiological need for it why and
so okay can i have a backyard hen fine
have a backyard hand like if that's
really gonna make you it's like when
people argue about honey like well i
would be vegan but like what about honey
like if you eat so much honey that like
that's really the thing stopping you
from being vegan but if i gave you
permission to have honey you'd be vegan
in every other way fine have honey but
that's not what the issue is the issue
is what we are supporting three times a
day more than that consuming as so much
meat dairy and eggs that we've never
consumed in the history of human
civilization that's what we're talking
about here not these little like but
what if i had a hand who get who dropped
some eggs yeah that tends to be their
like anecdote that they wouldn't
actually do themselves no yeah like in
an urban
high rise or like yeah
or maybe not but the point is it's not
the reality
but for the most part no for sure and um
the the factor of our of waste that you
brought up to be clear what she means is
like animal poop waste a lot of people
don't even think about where all this
animal poop goes like not even think
about it and then there's the factor of
like oh but look like the idealistic way
like they're saying the backyards are
also saying but the free range and the
grass but now literally not sustainable
literally we couldn't even cover this
entire like america
to be able to feed everybody on the
amount of
animal foods that you're advocating for
like it's literally not possible and
then there's the factor of what you're
saying like our physiological
lack of need for like a robin's egg or a
chicken egg the same goes for cow's milk
to me it's the most obvious one that
people are touting as like the super
food almost like like it's almost like
it's it's very interesting how it's like
it's literally like the most amazing
nature food but if somebody offered you
human breast milk which is actually like
in our species
would you drink it would you drink the
human breast milk like please tell me
would you be grossed out by that
or not like why would you at least not
want to drink the milk from your own
species right and maybe we should be
having like
factories of women breastfeeding right
so everyone can drink all the human no
we would never do that but that's more
in line with our species of what we
would
need if you were going to advocate at
all like if you don't need giraffe milk
you don't need monkey milk why do you
need cow's milk or goat milk yeah and
it's taking it even a step further it's
into adulthood there's no cow yeah who
into adulthood or steer or bull or
whatever would go to their mom at five
years old i mean they're you know they
have a shorter life span right five six
eight ten years old they're not going to
their moms and saying there's a little
bit yeah could use a little bit yeah mom
feel like were you talking about like
i gave it to you because i'm trying to
turn a 60 pound calf into a thousand
pound steer and we did it we're done you
don't need anymore we're done
that is one thing that i can never have
no one can answer that like if this
really is such a human food like why is
it that we are the only species that
drinks milk after we're weaned from our
mothers like please just really let that
sink in someone will be like no i've
seen a cat drink milk from a cow okay
i'm not talking about like a cat who's
wandering who's just trying to find food
to survive and there's like a dairy cow
over there no like
animal species we do not drink milk no
other animal no other mammal after
they're weaned off their mothers they
don't need it if the baby cow doesn't
need the milk after they're weaned off
their mothers why do we need it and
people will say well we're not cows no
we're not cows that's why we don't need
cows that's right like that is exactly
why we don't need it because we are not
physiologically designed like
a cow we do not need them and we're not
baby cows that's right so that is the
most fascinating to me like the the
justifications and the reasons and the
things that we're saying i look this is
good for us this and using euphemisms
like
um
you know grass-fed free range ethically
sourced and like it's nourishing it's
restoring it's
no it's not it's just not like if you
can't answer the simple fact as to
why no other species does this why are
we the only ones that need milk after
we're weaned off of our mothers and not
even from our own species that's right
that is that that one i could like go i
could do an entire episode on cow's
mouth like that one just really gets me
i've done several i've done several and
yeah and so and so this whole like idea
of romanticizing animal agriculture the
bottom line is there's no such thing as
a slaughter-free animal agriculture
system
as i was saying they're not in it for
altruism they're not in it because
they're going to keep them alive there
is no such thing every one of these
animals will be killed in the end
period full stop that is what we're
supporting when we're supporting so this
idea that we again have like the open
the free range over the cows and think
in the end they're all sent to slaughter
and one of the things i talk about again
in this willful blindness you know you
were saying slaughterhouses and glass
walls as i said even slaughterhouse
workers have their own willful blindness
and it goes for
there's so many ways we can still block
off what is true
so
so we can like farmers ranchers who
raise animals most of them don't go to
the slaughterhouse with the animals they
put them in a truck they probably feel
bad they didn't name them because they
know that naming creates an attachment
and they pretend that they're going to a
spa they have to do that as well so even
the ranchers who are raising these
animals even the slaughterhouse system
who are killing them we find ways
to
not face what we're really doing because
it's really painful and because it's
really wrong and because it's really
unnecessary so it's not even just us
like closing our eyes it's even the
people who are in the industry
themselves wow that's powerful really
good point and just the amount of like
the slaughterhouse workers and they're
the highest they have some of the
highest rates of depression and suicide
alcoholism addiction
violence because it is committing that
kind of violent act day after day
to you know to
feed people so that they don't have to
see what happens is really alarming and
even if you're not the one killing
because like i said the way a lot of the
systems are set up and let's face it
slaughterhouses have been consolidated
you don't have a lot of these small
slaughterhouses you have these massive
massive industrialized slaughterhouses
and so it's set up so that you have just
you know few people who are actually
doing the final cut
but but so even if you know even if that
weren't the case um it you're in a
culture of violence you're in a culture
of desensitization and that was when i
became vegan that was my
that was my turning point was when i saw
when i read and saw what the workers
were doing to the animals not because
they have to but because they can the
sadism that happens because they're so
desensitized to their own compassion and
they're so desensitized to the animal's
own suffering that they do things
because they're under such
huge amounts of pressure
and because they're in a culture of
violence it's unchecked violence so why
wouldn't you there's no consequences and
you're so desensitized i could not
stomach that and i couldn't be part of
that and that was the thing for me all i
have to do if there's ever a moment when
i ever think i never do but i i just
have to remember those images i don't
have to even
look at them i just have to remember the
images that i read about and saw about
when i first and it's it's a culture of
violence and that's why i use that word
very purposefully i don't use abuse i
don't use
torture it's just it's just unchecked
violence taking the life out of someone
who wants to live
and everybody wants to live is a bloody
difficult act that most of us don't want
to see most of us don't want to
participate in and if we can't even look
at it then we might not want to pay for
it yeah so two questions from that what
about people who are going well those
extreme examples of video footage of you
know people abusing animals and doing
horrible things those are just those are
just a very small percentage that you
know the vegans blow up on
on social media and or blow up online
and that's what that's what gets clicks
but that's not what it is majority
i would say read the book slaughterhouse
which was literally an investigative
journalist going around to all the
slaughterhouses that exist because again
there's very few of them and asked the
same questions of all of the workers the
same questions each time so that no one
could read that book and say it's just
one bad apple because it's a culture of
violence and that's my point is that
it's yeah you're going to get some
people who are more violent than others
i'm even saying that i don't think that
everybody who works in a slaughterhouse
is a sadist and i don't think everybody
who works in a slaughterhouse is violent
but you're in a culture of violence
where you're basically that's the status
quo and that's what you're doing you're
literally killing every single second
that's what you're doing every few
seconds you're killing or you're
dismembering or you're skinning i mean
that's what your job is right or you're
uh you're
stunning i mean like you're in this
culture of violence and so i i don't
think most people want to be there
so they don't want to be there but
that's what they're in and to to say
that there's just a bad apple just go
look at it yourself go to go go read the
books by the investigative journalists
who've done the work they can do
while they're still able to do it before
it's shut down and we don't get to see
what's actually true but people know in
their hearts what's really real yeah and
sometimes people say well that's why we
need more small-scale farming so because
it's the big massive because like
someone might say oh if i see like one
animal beside then that's not such a big
deal it's more so if it's like when you
see it in the masses and that's like
more impactful so we just need to be
doing small scale now listen if you're
advocating for that you're literally
saying that people need to be eating way
way less animal foods than they are now
like way way way less the only reason
it's come to this place it is now is
because of the demand of eating so much
animal foods so that's something really
important to consider too yeah and for
sure and again the when you're talking
about so i mean we're talking about usda
you have to have the usda
uh these are usda's slaughterhouses you
can't just have people just killing
people on their farms they're not doing
that there's gonna be a couple people
who are doing that it's the most small
scale that we're talking about but if
you're talking about i mean neiman ranch
was always held up as like the
the you know the bastion of the most
ethical they sell all of their cattle to
slaughter houses they don't have a
slaughterhouse because you know why
because people in marin county don't
want a slaughterhouse in their backyard
yeah so guess what happens they get
trucked to the slaughterhouses in iowa
in north carolina in these places in
california the parts of california
people don't want to go to um they're
going to slaughter houses so this idea
that there's like this euthanizing like
they're euthanized they're like playing
a lullaby for them
it's not true we just want to believe it
because we don't want to believe that
we're contributing to something that is
so
like anathema to what we really believe
yeah so you can say that it's just not
happening go ask the farms themselves go
ask them how they kill them go ask them
which slaughterhouse they send them to
oh yeah go ask them what the
transportation how long they're on a
truck before without water before they
get to the slaughterhouse go ask them
what happens to the baby cows don't
listen to us go ask the farmers
themselves they're the ones who are
doing this
absolutely they're farmers they're
you know
and a lot of them would even say that
that's not how they used to farm or
ranch they're now in the system that is
exploiting them as much as exploiting
the animals they don't get to decide how
they want to feed the animals they don't
get to decide how they want to treat
them because the systems are mostly
owned by these large multinational
corporations who have dictated this
cycle of
they have to feed this kind of feed and
make sure they're giving them hormones
and if you try and break out of that
system you've
you're you're you're so deep in debt
that you that you can't fight them and
you're forced to farm in a way that is
even against what you believe go talk to
the farmers yourself plenty of people
have done expose on this
they're suffering too they don't want to
treat their animals this way but they're
suck they're stuck in the system so if
you don't want that to happen
you want to support those farmers don't
stop supporting the whole system there's
no way around it there's a lot of people
trans transforming their farms into
plant farms and they're seeing the
benefits that's right that's right
that's right because it's a business and
like you know you look at um one of the
things i love is when we go to wineries
and like they used to be a ranch right i
mean this is what it looks like this is
what it looks like we're going to evolve
away from this it's just that we're so
bloody slow we're going to this is not
sustainable it is the worst business
model if anybody walked into a silicon
valley you know uh um
you know uh um
who's gonna support someone investor and
they walked in with a business plan that
said okay
we bring animals into this world they
gotta be pregnant for nine months first
so hang on you gotta wait nine months
before like you get the commodity but
once they're born then we kill we can
keep them alive for six months we give
them a lot of food we give them a lot of
feed and we spend a lot of money and we
need a lot of land for that and then
we're gonna truck them and we're gonna
kill them and then they go that's the
worst business model who wants to see
their profit come
18 months after the thing and like it's
not even that great a profit to be
honest that's why we have government
subsidies etc so like it's the worst
business model it's going to fade and
we're going to see them turning to other
kinds of plant-based agriculture it
might not be you know might not be
alfalfa or well actually it is alfalfa
right now because of that's what the
cows are eating but it might not be you
know soy beans for soy milk but it's
going to be a a model that's going to be
sustainable not to mention most of the
soybean grown today is fed today i'm
using soy beans as an example it might
not be broccoli but it could be wine it
could be vineyards it could be olive
groves like it's it's moving in that
direction it's just this is a pretty
entrenched system and it's it's big and
also there's the aspect of just like
massive scale farming where they're
doing you know model cropping and
all of that there's so many different
problems and so i think that's really
important to preface that there's
problems within a lot of just our food
system in general
um but being able to make daily choices
and how to get closer and closer to our
roots and for me part of that is growing
our own food because that's where you
absolutely know where that food is
coming from you know what's in the soil
you know what you're taking care of and
what you're supporting and so that's one
of our goals and i know that that's not
everybody's goal nor is that everybody
going to want to do that
but that's something that's really
valuable to me and my husband because
we're like look we know what's going
into this and how we're supporting it
ethically and
all that too so what are your thoughts
on that yeah no of course i mean
absolutely i mean look this is these are
issues around agriculture i mean yes the
agricultural revolution ten thousand
years ago changed who we are as humans
we're not going to undo that we it did
change that's why the population grew
that's why we were able to not have to
migrate we were able to stay in one
place families grew and this is what it
this is what agriculture did for us so
like okay that's that definitely changed
who we are
you know we can't
just demonize this thing that was like
this massive revolution that happened
that changed who we are as beings
but of course we can make mindful
choices when we can and so you know you
said it and something i say all the time
is my hope for people is that their
deepest values are reflected in their
daily behavior that's all i would ask of
people is
when we can do better when we can know
better do better and know better that's
all we can do so is it always going to
be perfect no you know are you always
going to be able to find organic
strawberries that are affordable for you
no so okay do the best you can get
strawberries because it's going to be
good for you wash them or go to the
farmer's market maybe get ones that
aren't certified organic because that's
a whole different certification process
but if they're not sprayed that's still
better blueberries they don't tend to be
sprayed you can get blueberries that
aren't organic okay great like you know
there's just that's that's what life is
yeah talking to your farmers like
getting and getting to know where your
food is coming from so you know the
ethical practices yeah just taking the
time to k to do the things like you said
that are already in your values for sure
yeah that's what we have to do i think
we have to navigate this all the time
it's never going to be perfect but
there's a lot we can do i mean that's to
me that's the ultimate hope is that
there are a lot of problems and there
are a lot of issues the question we have
to ask ourselves is do we want to be
part of the solution or do we want to be
part of the problem i mean it's one
thing you know people ask me a lot like
do you really think it's possible that
people can make a difference i mean it's
what i've devoted my life to and people
will say so do you really think that
people can make a difference and my
answer is no i don't think people can
make a difference i know people do make
a difference everything we do has an
impact everything we buy has an impact
on someone or something else so we don't
get to decide whether we can make a
difference or not we get to decide only
if the difference we inevitably make is
negative or positive that's it there are
no neutral choices so it's never going
to be perfect but that's my that's my
ask is that we constantly ask ourselves
do i want the difference i'm making to
be negative or do i want the difference
i'm making to be positive because you're
going to make a difference no matter
what but you have the choice to make of
whether you want what kind of impact you
want to have mm-hmm i love that i love
that you said that it's so true and
sometimes it's overwhelming for people
like they're like oh gosh this is so
much to think about like i'm so busy and
i can't and if that's where you're at
like try to see where in life you can
slow down so that you can start making
more choices that are in line with your
ethics and with your values because it's
true like it's easy to get caught up in
the just the rat race of life in the
world that we live in where everything
is so fast-paced and you have and then
you have this excuse like i literally
have no time to look into the brands i'm
buying or the food and you know all that
aspect but but really you do have a
choice to find ways to slow your life
down and even if it's only little ways
like start in little ways to be able to
slow your life down so you can make
those choices
um
but i also do feel just like bringing it
back to this aspect of like when people
stop being vegan of like how to stop
being all that all that stuff i do feel
like um love and and empathy for people
who like we said earlier people are just
doing their best they're trying to
figure out what is the best and most
people are just doing what they feel is
best with the information that they have
and i want to be clear that like i have
a lot of friends who are not vegan or
plant-based and i love them just the
same and like trying to just when it
comes down to whether you're vegan or
not listening to this like try and just
have empathy for other people and like
what their their lens that they're
looking through because everybody is
looking through a different lens based
on their experiences that they've had
um
but just like understanding that like
people are just doing their best
but but at the same time helping people
to
to understand that like people are gonna
stop being vegan in your life like it's
gonna happen that's just the way just
like people are gonna stop other diets
too it's just maybe you're not gonna
hear about it as much because they don't
have as much of a conviction um most
people don't stay on all different types
of diets right but when it comes to
veganism this there is a conviction of
all because it's talking about exactly
what you just said like living in line
with your with your values that you
already have and you know there are
multiple friends of mine who like yeah
yeah i hear you i see it and i like
you're right i do want to live more in
compassion that way but like i'm
struggling and just like meeting people
where they're at you know for sure do
you have any thoughts
[Music]
yeah i mean that's i mean you know
that's what it comes down to is just
it's it literally is just coming down to
being authentic and and just doing what
you really know to be true in your heart
and if you find yourself looking for
confirmation bias and you're going to
the people who are going to tell you
what you want to hear you can do that
but it sounds like you might want
something different and we're just here
offering a perspective that is very
common it's a very you know we're all
going through this thing called life and
it's not easy all the time and it's
going to throw us curveballs but if
we're just putting one foot in front of
the other and just taking the next right
step and being honest with ourselves and
raising the bar a little bit i think
that's a good thing and i think
everybody has the ability to do that and
everybody has the the potential to do
that yeah and for anyone who is vegan
like just keep like shining bright and
like reminding yourselves of the reason
why the reasons why you are vegan in a
non-vegan world and um
to maybe not be remind yourself maybe
just to take a step back and not be so
easily influenced by maybe like what
everybody else is doing and figure out
ways that you can not be so easily
influenced by the social pressures the
cultural aspects or when somebody around
you stops me and says this or that like
like check in with yourself you know and
all that and know your why i think
knowing your why is really important and
and and bearing witness to that every so
often you don't have to stare you don't
have to look at it all the time but
revisiting what compelled you to make
the change in the first place i think is
really important it's checking in with
yourself
and uh and knowing your why and yeah and
acting on it that's good i think we
covered a lot we did what um should
people know about your book the joyful
vegan like to know if it's right for
them like who's it for yeah that's a
good question i mean i i want everyone
who's ever wondered
why people
even become vegan stop being vegan
resist being vegan just understand my
favorite chapters are the early chapters
on willful blindness because it really
it it really
it really demonstrates what we're all
facing and we're all facing this um this
denial of what is really true and
socially you know in the industry family
wise personally so i really think it's
very helpful to look through that lens
because
it also helps us understand that people
aren't evil they're just blind and that
is a difference that's a big difference
because it's very easy to condemn people
even if you don't know them it's very
easy to look at them and condemn them
for what you see them doing wrong
versus seeing people as protecting
themselves as being afraid as caring but
not really knowing what to do as being
uninformed that's very different than
you're just a big old whatever right i
mean you're just evil you're just bad
you're just cruel you don't care that
idea that this judgment that people who
are not vegan don't care i mean you know
there's that very popular um
campaign that says why eat one but not
the other
it's a very important question to ask
but there's a very simple answer it's
because we weren't taught to eat dogs i
mean like it's so simple it's right in
our face people were conditioned to
consider cows edible we don't consider
giraffes edible but other people do
right so it's just a conditioning the
point is it's really important to
mirror that for people for them to go
wait a second what's the difference in
terms not of how i see them but of how
the animals are they feel the same pain
whether they're a giraffe or a cow or a
dog they feel the same
sense of dread they feel the same fear
they feel the same
desire to live right that's what that
campaign does but what happens is that
campaign gets put out and then people
say you say you're compassionate you
love your dog but clearly you don't love
animals because you're eating other
animals don't you see like there's just
this like assumption that everybody sees
the world as you do not people don't we
all see the world through a different
lens we once didn't see the world
through that lens that everyone's so
confident they see through now right we
have to just bring it down and guide
people
to their own compassion not to our own
righteousness and i think that's what
just really frustrates me about some of
the some of the campaigns that i see is
that we're really missing an opportunity
to guide people along and to mirror back
to them
what is true for them
so i just come from the place of i think
everybody does really want to do the
best thing i don't think people wake up
in the morning figuring out how they can
be as violent against animals as
possible
but i do think that people don't wake up
in the morning and say how can i be as
compassionate as possible so again i'm
putting it back on the person who is
we're all responsible we all have our
own agency so i don't believe you're
like un you know kind and cruel you want
to hurt animals because you're eating
them that's not my position i don't
believe that i was a good kind
compassionate person who actually did
help animals i was an animal advocate
before i was vegan so i i don't think
that people who are eating animals are
walking because they're evil and cruel
and
i don't think any of that but i would
say are you waking up every day saying
how can i be the most compassionate
person i can be and reflect that in my
behavior that's what i would ask of
people love that and your book is a
great source for people to go to when
they're trying to be like navigate this
topic navigate this topic navigate this
topic of just living our values in this
complicated world in a world that really
wants us to keep eating animal products
so how to navigate that that's that's
definitely what that book does and at
the end of it to give you the confidence
to give you the
the
enthusiasm and the joy i mean we didn't
talk really about that
that's what i call my book and i call my
brand is the joyful vegan i call it that
on purpose i have conviction i have
opinions but i live my life every day to
be
to reflect the joy that is in i believe
in
this world and i'm
i i
it's such an honor to be able to do it
through this through this means through
through living according to my own
values of compassion and wellness like
there's just no other way i can find to
reflect that and in in waking up every
morning and saying how can i live as
compassionately as possible
there's so much joy in that and that's
what i really want to convey and i think
the book conveys that yes i i'm so glad
you brought that up because you're right
we're like tackling all these topics but
really at the foundation of it for me
and it sounds like for you too like it
is a joyful
really fulfilling thing to live in this
way and i find i just find so much
goodness from it from being vegan living
vegan raising my face seeing all the
benefits and the ways that it's
supporting and helping you know in other
forms like helping the animals and also
better for the environment and all of it
plays out together and for me i just
found that over the years even from the
beginning maybe part of that is my
personality of just like the confidence
that i have and not everybody has that
same kind of confidence but like for
like what other people are doing does it
really matter it's like this is what i
know is best for us and it's like
helpful i think for people to kind of
arm and learn that for themselves to be
able to
navigate life in that way and tap into
that totally and that and that actually
is what the joyful vegan does it gives
you those skills so you might not have
an innate personality that's you know
that's outgoing and you know you want to
put yourself out there and rock the boat
and and i talk a lot about that in the
joyful vegans so it actually gives you
the tools and the skills to be able to
do that and that's one of my greatest um
joys and i'm really grateful i've heard
from a lot of people over the years who
said you know i was kind of
self-effacing about it i didn't really
talk about it i didn't want people to
judge me i didn't want them to have the
wrong conclusions about who i am i was
so i never really talked about how i was
vegan and using the tools that i've that
i give i mean through this book but it's
been through the decades i've been doing
this work they say i changed just the
way i thought about who i am in relation
to everybody and i came with just a
different demeanor and confident and and
detached and oh my gosh everyone reacted
very differently to me than they had
before so so wherever you are on the
spectrum of personality like doesn't
matter there are skills we can all gain
and and it's definitely something i've
been talking about in the book i mean my
podcast is you know it's in its 16th
year so i've been talking about this
stuff for a really long time but
distilled it in this book and i'm really
proud of it and i'm really proud
that people are reading it and it's
really giving them the confidence and
the
um the peace that they were hoping to
get that's awesome i feel like it's a
great way to end it i think it's a good
way yeah i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you're listening and i'm
so glad that you got to come on the show
this is perfect so good to be here thank
you so much and i hope everybody also
enjoys it if you have any questions you
know where to find me i'm a joyful vegan
anywhere so joyful vegan on social media
and on my website perfect yay thank you
so much all right we're gonna end it
here yeah bye
[Music]
you